wer hier bei phoenix den ganzen tag lang
live übertragen jeanette klag wird sie
begleiten es geht heute vor allem um die
umstrittene lieferung schwerer waffen in
die ukraine
ja guten morgen aus berlin nachdem die
bundesregierung in dieser woche ja
angekündigt hat und den weg freigemacht
hat für lieferung schwerer waffen für
lieferung von panzern aus deutschen
industrie beständen an die ukraine haben
heute die abgeordneten die möglichkeit
darüber zu diskutieren also wie viel
unterstützung wird es geben für diesen
schritt der bundesregierung der durchaus
eine zäsur war den weg für schwere
waffen für die ukraine freizumachen von
seiten der ampel
koalition aber auch von seiten der
größten oppositionsfraktion der cdu csu
fraktion und ich freue mich dass ich
heute morgen zwei gäste bei mir am set
habe nämlich zwei ausgewiesene experten
für sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
agnieszka broker darf ich als begrüßen
für die grünen die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende und johann wadephul
für die cdu/csu-fraktion der
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
ja wir wollen darauf schauen auf das
thema der waffenlieferung das thema ist
umstritten gewesen in den letzten wochen
tatsächlich jetzt hat die
bundesregierung den weg frei gemacht
es wird heute einen ungewöhnlichen
schulterschluss geben zwischen den
fraktionen die die ampel regierung
tragen und der größten
oppositionsfraktion der cdu csu fraktion
denn es gibt einen gemeinsamen antrag in
dem diese lieferung von schweren waffen
unterstützt werden soll wenn er denn
heute wieso sein soll mutmaßlich
abgestimmt wird und auch zugestimmt wird
frau becker wenn wir jetzt in diesen
antrag schauen und auf die linie schauen
die jetzt in zukunft für die nächsten
wochen gelten soll wie sieht die denn
aus wenn es um die lieferung von
schweren waffen an die ukraine geht sie
sieht so aus dass wir vor allem ein
instrument brauchen mit dem wir schnell
den einsatz von schweren waffen auch
ermöglichen können das ist der so
genannte ringtausch das heißt dass
partner aus alten beständen aus der
sowjetzeit gerät liefern panzer liefern
und wir sie dann bei den partnern mit
unserem material ersetzen und
gleichzeitig aber müssen auch jetzt vor
die vorbereitungen getroffen werden um
komplexere und muss gerne systeme auch
aus den beständen aus deutschland der
industrie oder möglicherweise der
bundeswehr auch auf den weg zu bringen
weil es eben ausbildung munition
ersatzteile wartungen braucht und
deshalb muss das zusammen im gleichklang
laufen und diese möglichkeit eröffnet
der antrag war wohl eigentlich hatte die
unionsfraktion einen wesentlich
weitergehenden antrag sie haben
tatsächlich auch gefordert dass man aus
den beständen der bundeswehr auch
kampfpanzer beispielsweise schicken
sollte und größtmögliche unterstützung
an rüstungsgütern der ukraine liefern
sollte jetzt haben sie diesen antrag
zurückgezogen haben sich dem der ampel
angeschlossen warum war das kernanliegen
erfüllt wird und zwar im wort das heißt
im beschluss heute aber auch im
praktischen tun es ist richtig an den
ringtausch zu machen es ist richtig die
ukrainische armee zunächst mit dem gerät
auszustatten was sie kennt das ist altes
sowjetisches
material das ist gut das ist richtig es
ist darüber hinaus richtig weiteres
deutsches material zu liefern wie den
gebhard panzer der wird nicht sofort
verfügbar sein aber der wird später die
ukraine auch unterstützen können und
genau das beschließen wir jetzt im
deutschen bundestag das war ja eine
schwere geburt man hat gemerkt die ampel
koalition hat sich dabei sehr schwer
getan gab gewichtige stimmen dafür die
fdp hat es beschlossen wichtige stimmen
auch bei den grünen waren frühzeitig
dafür der bundeskanzler hat sich sehr
schwergetan
das war bedauerlich aber wenn am ende
wie eine einigung haben dann ist es
unsere politik als cdu/csu
außenpolitisch hier auf gemeinsamkeit zu
setzen damit die deutsche politik im
europäischen konzert geschlossen
wahrgenommen wird trotzdem ist es
erstaunlich den ringtausch
beispielsweise da kommen wir gleich noch
mal zu den haben sie selbst in der
letzten woche noch eher abgelehnten
haben gesagt das ist eigentlich nicht
genug also was hat sich denn geändert
nein ja genau ich habe gesagt das ist
nicht genug es ist nicht genug aber es
wird jetzt noch mehr gemacht der gebhard
ist ja dazu gekommen und das ist ein
komplexes aber ein sehr gutes deutsches
waffensystem was zusätzlich jetzt
geliefert wird der ringtausch allein
macht es nicht der ist gut er ist
richtig die bundesregierung hat sich
schrittweise nach vorne bewegt aber in
die richtige richtung und dann wollen
wir auch nicht besserwisserisch sein
sondern es ist einfach wichtig dass wir
in zentralen fragen in der
demokratischen mitte des hauses wir
haben an den beiden rändern schon sehr
viel extreme position dass wir danach
zusammen stehen frau burke der
ringtausch sie haben es angesprochen
steht im antrag drin die bundesregierung
hat es auch schon angekündigt wird auch
schon gemacht nato-partner slowenien in
dem fall das ist schon geplant den atem
partner slowenien gibt der ukraine
panzer von sowjetischer bauart und
deutschland liefert slowenien sozusagen
dann panzer nach um die bestände auf zu
auf zu erhöhen sozusagen genau warum
kann man denn so wie in den panzer
liefern aber der ukraine nicht direkt es
ist auch gar kein gegeneinander sondern
es geht wirklich um die zeitliche
abfolge und es ist wichtig dass beide
maßnahmen im zusammenhang gesehen werden
weil die entscheidungen modernere und
komplexere systeme zu liefern einfach
voraussetzung es voll ist denn es muss
ausbildung sichergestellt sein die
lieferung von munition auch die frage
ersatzteile und wartungen wir sehen
wirklich mutige ukrainische streitkräfte
die beachtliches geleistet haben in den
letzten wochen aber jetzt wenn man
möchte dass schweres gerät ganz
unmittelbar sehr schnell zum einsatz
kommt ist der ringtausch das richtige
instrument aber es gibt ja auch in dem
antrag und auch in den entscheidungen
der bundesregierung die klare
bereitschaft auch selbst schweres gerät
aus deutschland zuliefern ja aber das
war es jetzt angekündigt wurde in dieser
woche die zäsur dass diese gepard panzer
alte bestände der bundeswehr die von
einem rüstungsunternehmen die dort in
den beständen sind weitergegeben werden
können da soll jetzt die ausfuhr
genehmigt werden aber wenn sie sagen die
ausbildung muss gewährleistet sein auf
diesem system da gibt es jetzt kritik
ist dieser gepard panzer überhaupt das
richtige um die ukraine jetzt schnell zu
unterstützen weil die ausbildung dauert
beispielsweise unheimlich lang also ist
das das richtige gerät oder ist es mehr
symbolpolitik dass man jetzt was
freigeben wollte nein es ist auf jeden
fall das richtige gerät aber wenn man
nur den gepard panzer jetzt genehmigt
hätte dann hätte man unmittelbar für die
nächsten monate nichts anzubieten
den menschen jetzt in dem kampf den sie
ja täglich führen um ihr leben ihre
freiheit ihre sicherheit etwas
anzubieten und sie dabei zu unterstützen
und deshalb müssen diese maßnahmen im
gleichklang laufen und so auch in der
zeitlichen abfolge stopfen erwarten sie
haben gestern die
bundesministerin hier im bundestag
selbst noch nach diesem gebhard panzern
gefragt und waren durchaus skeptisch ob
das so das richtige gerät ist jetzt
sagen sie doch eigentlich ein richtiger
schritt versteht nicht weil es ein
großer schritt für die bundesregierung
ist sie hat das ja vorher abgelehnt was
der bundeskanzler hat es abgelehnt so
etwas zu machen und ich will einfach
würdigen und ich finde es einfach auch
richtig dass der schritt jetzt getan
wird dass wir deutsches gerät einen
deutschen panzer liefern ich will jetzt
nicht auf die idee gekommen den gebhard
als erstes zu nehmen weil er das
komplexeste waffensystem ist ich kenne
den recht gut weil ich in der
truppengattung gedient habe da braucht
man mindestens ein halbes jahr warum die
soldaten daran auszubilden damit der
sinnvoll eingesetzt werden kann ich
hätte er den maler geliefert das ist ein
schützenpanzer der hier auch zur
verfügung steht oder den leopard 1 der
ist noch etwas komplizierter aber auch
noch einfacher zu bedienen als der
gepard ich will jetzt wirklich mal in
den vordergrund stellen die
bundesregierung hat sich hier bewegt und
sie hat ja auch zugesagt mehr zu tun es
ist hat eine konferenz mit den usa
gegeben in ramstein vorgestern wo man
zugesagt habe jetzt monatlich sich zu
treffen und zu schauen was kann man mehr
tun und wenn wir jetzt sehen es wird der
ringtausch gemacht das heißt es wird
sowjetisches material geliefert dass die
sofort bedienen können dann stelle ich
mir vor dass man schaut ob man nicht
noch weiteres material hat was einfacher
zu bedienen ist als der gepard in der
zwischenzeit liefern kann und später
kann dann auch der gepard unterstützen
wir müssen uns leider darauf einstellen
keiner weiß das dass dieser krieg länger
dauert das ist eine befürchtung die wir
haben müssen und ich glaube das ist auch
ein signal an putin zu zeigen dass wir
uns auf einen längeren konflikt
einstellen und nicht morgen oder
übermorgen die unterstützung der ukraine
beenden sondern dass wir auch gewillt
sind das länger zu führen immer
natürlich mit dem ziel möglichst schnell
möglichst wirklich am liebsten morgen zu
einem ende dieses krieges zu kommen
frau gruber ja die ukraine müsste
vielleicht noch länger unterstützt
werden wenn jetzt heute mit diesem
antrag auch eine große unterstützung aus
den reihen des bundestages für die
bundesregierung kommt wo sind eigentlich
die grenzen mit was wir die ukraine an
waffen ausrüsten und ausrüsten wollen es
ist erstmal wichtig dass diese starke
zeichen der solidarität von der so
großen mehrheit des deutschen
parlamentes kommen dass die
unterstützung für die ukraine ebenso
immens und so starkes und auch in
deutschland so breit getragen wird aber
natürlich fragt sich jeder von uns was
können wir noch mehr tun jeden tag und
gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich auch
alle eine verantwortung und es ist eine
linie beschrieben war wurden in den
letzten wochen die auch bereit als
konsens in diesem hohen hause gilt auch
von der bundesregierung geschrieben
worden dass man eben nicht direkt in das
militärische geschehen eingreift dass
man nicht direkt zur konfliktpartei wird
weil damit natürlich extreme risiken
verboten verbunden sind umso mehr muss
man alles andere tun was man tun kann wo
sind die grenzen darauf wollte ich auch
ein bisschen hinaus wo sind die grenzen
dessen was deutschland liefern kann und
eine unterstützung leisten kann aber
beispielsweise bestände der bundeswehr
haben wir jetzt mehrfach gehört von der
verteidigungsministerin auch vom kanzler
sind leer oder also die
möglichkeiten aus den beständen der
bundeswehr zu liefern sind in der tat
schon sehr weit ausgeschöpft aber umso
mehr muss man dann eben schauen was auch
mit blick auf die industrie auf altes
gerät der bundeswehr was bei der
industrie steht auch möglich ist dass
müssen immer wieder viele komplexe
fragen
behandelt werden und auch mit
internationalen partnern besprochen
werden das beispiel der panzerhaubitze
in kooperation mit den niederlanden wo
gerät von dort möglicherweise geliefert
wird und deutschland sich dann um die
ausbildung kümmert das sind natürlich
fragen müssen geklärt werden bevor so
etwas verkündet werden kann aber daran
arbeitet die bundesregierung tag für tag
sehr wohl ich hatte bei der union in den
letzten zwei wochen ein bisschen den
eindruck dass sie nicht ganz glauben
dass man aus den beständen der
bundeswehr nichts mehr liefern kann also
sehen sie da
ist da vielleicht doch noch ein
unterschied sehen sie die möglichkeiten
durchaus mehr zu liefern und nicht sich
darauf zurück zu ziehen wir brauchen das
für die eigene bündnisse
landesverteidigung ja in der tat würde
ich sagen also ich glaube wir müssen
einfach lernen
auch ein bisschen selbstkritisch dass
sachen auszuschließen nicht klug ist wir
sind ja immer neue schritte gegangen die
wir vor zwei wochen noch nicht für
möglich gehalten haben was ging für die
lieferung von waffen überhaupt von
schweren waffen jetzt erst recht und
auch für die lieferung von waffen aus
beständen der bundeswehr natürlich ist
die bundeswehr sehr knapp ausgestattet
auch unter ausgestattet das ist ja
unstreitig deswegen wollen wir sie ja
auch stärker ausstatten und reden über
100 milliarden sondervermögen das
vollkommen klar aber die wir sind ja
jetzt nicht in der situation zum glück
und das soll ja auch nicht der fall
werden dass deutschland und das
bündnisgebiet direkt bedroht ist das
heißt ich würde die frage ob jetzt nicht
nenne ein beispiel 40 marder bei der
bundeswehr vorhanden sind oder
vielleicht jetzt der ukraine zur
verfügung gestellt werden mindestens mal
offen lassen ich finde wir müssen jede
option jetzt
auch prüfen denn am ende ist es so die
freiheit und die sicherheit auch
deutschlands ganz europas wird jetzt in
der ukraine verteidigt das muss man
sehen wenn dieser krieg nicht gestoppt
wird dann wird er weiter gehen russland
hat schon klar kriegsziele formuliert
die auf moldau abzielen das heißt immer
näher an das gebiet auch der nato
herankommen der nächste start ist an
rumänien das ist nato gebiet und
deswegen je früher wir putin ein klares
stopp signal senden umso besser
ich möchte noch mit ihnen auf einer
weiteren punkt in diesem antrag gucken
der insgesamt 40 forderungen an die
bundesregierung gerichtet wir werden
dazu ja ab 9 dann gleich noch in der
debatte etwas hören aber das knüpft
daran an was sie habe gesagt haben im
antrag steht nämlich auch neben der
unterstützung der ukraine verbindet uns
das gemeinsame ziel zu verhindern dass
russland den krieg auf weitere staaten
ausdehnt im russischen staatsfernsehen
wird ja schon offen darüber gesprochen
beispielsweise die bundesregierung wird
aufgefordert den ausbau der
truppenpräsenz der nato an ihrer
ostflanke durch weitere soldatinnen und
soldaten der bundeswehr zu unterstützen
was kommt da noch auf die bundeswehr auf
deutschland zu dass wir auch mit einer
stärkeren präsenz und das ist ja auch
direkt seit kriegsbeginn geschehen auch
gerade bei unseren baltischen partnern
vor ort sind auch mit blick auf den
südosten des bündnisgebietes verstärken
das kann sich um luftraumüberwachung
halten dass die kann um die
stationierung von truppen gehen das sind
alles fragen die derzeit in der nato
diskutiert werden aber wir spüren
natürlich dass die sorgen und ängste die
unsere ost und mitteleuropäischen
partnerinnen und partner seit jahren
hatten sehr real waren und dass wir dort
hätten besser zuhören müssen und deshalb
auch die reise der bundes
außenministerin ins baltikum mit den
entsprechenden zusagen ein sehr sehr
wichtiges zeichen dass wir
zusammenstehen und da kein zweifel daran
aufkommen kann die aussenministerin war
in den baltischen staaten litauen
beispielsweise sind 1500 soldaten
stationiert 1000 davon von der
bundeswehr
wie viel kann die bundeswehr überhaupt
leisten wie sie derzeit dasteht und was
sie derzeit noch an sonstigen aufgaben
eher leisten ich glaube die bundeswehr
kann die bündnisverpflichtungen
vollständig erfüllen das ist
anstrengend das nimmt viele kapazitäten
in anspruch aber es gelingt es auch
wichtig dass wir diese signale senden
ich finde es sehr gut und war sehr
wichtig dass die aussenministerin da war
weil natürlich gerade im baltikum sehr
genau geschaut wird oder ob deutschland
an der seite dieser länder steht ich
meine da gibt's denn traumatische
erfahrung aus dem letzten jahrhundert
als schrecklicher weise hitler mit
stalin pakt geschlossen hat und
deutschland auf dem rücken dieser länder
nicht nur politik gemacht hat sondern
auch ein krieg geführt hat deswegen
haben wir eine besondere verantwortung
die nehmen wir wahr aber vollkommen klar
ist die bundeswehr muss besser
ausgestattet werden deswegen haben wir
darüber gestern hier diskutiert da wird
es auch den schulterschluss wieder der
demokratischen mittel glaube ich am ende
geben wir müssen für die bundeswehr mehr
tun wir müssen für die
verteidigungsfähigkeit europas mehr tun
und wir können uns das ist ja auch die
lehre der letzten jahre nicht immer
darauf verlassen dass es so ist wie
jetzt dass die amerikaner sich so stark
engagieren das heißt wir sind ein stück
weit auf uns selber mehr gestellt den
antrag der heute beschlossen werden soll
der hat keine sozusagen gesetz
gesetzliche wirkung also erst nicht
gesetz bindend für die bundesregierung
trotzdem wird es natürlich ein starkes
signal sein ihr fraktionsvorsitzender
friedrich merz hat gestern gesagt keiner
tut es sich macht es sich leicht mit der
lieferung an schweren waffen ist das
vielleicht in der diskussion ein
bisschen kurz gekommen frau brooke ja
also eine diskussion der letzten tage
ist vor allem auch der punkt zu kurz
gekommen warum es diese
waffenlieferungen geben muss die
sanktionen waren richtig und sie sind
hart aber sie haben nicht dazu geführt
dass dieser krieg unmittelbar gestoppt
wird das einzige was die russischen
truppen bisher aufgehalten hat das
einzige was zur befreiung von besetzten
gebieten in denen massivste
menschenrechtsverletzungen verübt worden
sind beigetragen hat das war der mutige
widerstand der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer und diesen müssen wir
unterstützen und deshalb haben wir uns
diese entscheidung nicht leicht gemacht
aber deshalb ist sie am ende des tages
auch richtig weil wir sonst unmittelbar
diesen brutalen krieg kalkül nichts
entgegen setzen würden vielen dank in
beiden wir müssen rein gehen wie werden
sie in der debatte auch hören herr
wadenpohl für die cdu/csu-fraktion und
frau broker für die grünen vielen dank
und die bundestags vizepräsidentin
katrin göring eckardt die hat den
plenarsaal betreten und wir hören wir an
die sitzung wird jetzt eröffnet
die sitzung ist eröffnet und wir
beginnen mit zwei wahlen auf vorschlag
der fraktionen der spd soll der kollege
dr johannes fechner als nachfolger für
den kollegen machen musste mir als
ordentliches mitglied sowie der kollege
majid daran mit tokio als nachfolger für
den abgeordneten von doktor johannes
fechner als stellvertretendes mitglied
des wahlprüfungsausschusses gewählt
werden ich sehe dass darüber
einvernehmen besteht dann können wir so
verfahren herzlichen dank damit sind die
kolleginnen gewählt und als mitglied und
stellvertretendes mitglied des
wahlprüfungsausschusses gemäß § 3 absatz
2 gewählt als mittel des aufsichtsrates
der agentur für sprung innovation soll
der kollege holger mann als nachfolger
für die kolleginnen jasmin fach chemie
gewählt werden auch diesbezüglich sehe
ich keinen widerspruch dann ist der
kollege man gewählt wir kommen zur
tagesordnung der tagesordnungspunkt 8
wird heute in verbundener beratung mit
zusatzpunkt drei als erster punkt
aufgerufen der als erster punkt
aufgerufen werden sollte wird abgesetzt
die koalitionsfraktionen und die
fraktion der cdu csu haben sich auf
einen gemeinsamen antrag mit dem titel
frieden und freiheit in europa
verteidigen umfassende unterstützung für
die ukraine verständigt auf verlangen
der fraktion der cdu/csu findet heute
nach den wahlen eine aktuelle stunde
statt mit dem thema von der
bundesregierung angekündigte kehrtwende
bei energiepreisen so schnell wie
möglich richtig und unbürokratisch
umsetzen
tagesordnungspunkt 21 wird abgesetzt
stattdessen soll tagesordnungspunkt 23
aufgerufen werden
tagesordnungspunkt 22 wird nach
tagesordnungspunkt 24 aufgerufen dazu
sehe ich keinen widerspruch dann ist das
so beschlossen
und ich hoffe auf zusatzpunkt drei
beratung des antrags der fraktionen der
spd cdu/csu bündnis 90/die grünen und
fdp mit dem titel frieden und freiheit
in europa verteidigen umfassende
unterstützung für die ukraine wir werden
nachher über diesen antrag
namentlich abstimmen
ich eröffne die aussprache und gebe das
wort für bündnis 90 die grünen der
kollegin britta haßelmann
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen seit dem 24
februar ist unsere welt eine andere
mitten in europa tobt ein furchtbarer
krieg
völkerrechtswidrig mit kriegsverbrechen
und an brutalität und grausamkeit die
wir jeden tag erleben kaum vorstellbar
dieser angriffskrieg bricht in
eklatanter weise mit dem
internationalen recht auf dass sich die
weltgemeinschaft gemeinsam verständigt
hat ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht
seit dem 24 2 beginnt jeder morgen mit
neuen schrecklichen nachrichten aus der
ukraine
und beginnt jeder tag mit trauer mit
schmerz mit fassungslosigkeit über das
ausmaß der zerstörung über das leid von
menschen über tod über kinder auf der
flucht die bilder von und vorstellung
von menschen die durften in bunkern
hausen ermordete zivilistinnen und
zivilisten tote soldaten und
vergewaltigung als kriegswaffe gegen
frauen inzwischen systematisch
eingesetzt der krieg zerstört unsere
europäische friedens- und sicherheitsrat
nung und ist ein angriff auf unsere
werte von freiheit von demokratie und
selbstbestimmung
wir alle in diesen krieg aufs schärfste
und die russische regierung muss alle
kampfhandlungen
unverzüglich einstellen
seit zwei monaten
arbeiten wir
ununterbrochen
und mit nachdruck daran hier im
parlament in der bundesregierung mit
unseren europäischen partnern in g7 mit
der weltgemeinschaft der internationalen
staatengemeinschaft
ununterbrochen daran wie können wir
hilfe und unterstützung bieten dazu
gehört finanzielle unterstützung
wirtschaftliche unterstützung
humanitäre unterstützung
und auf die unterstützung mit waffen wir
ringen
seit diesem tag um ehrliche antworten
wir wägen ab wir zweifeln
ja und wir haben
aber und wir entscheiden und das ist am
ende das was zählt
niemand weiß heute genau
was
jetzt meine damen und herren und mich
beruhigen die die alle heute schon ganz
genau wissen was gestern und übermorgen
zu tun ist ich finde es wichtig zum
ausdruck zu bringen
wie schwer die situation ist und wie
darum gerungen werden muss was die
richtigen antworten sind wir haben
inzwischen fünf harte sanktionspaket
gegen russland und die russische führung
vereinbart wichtig und notwendig alles
getragen im europäischen kontext der
nato der weltgemeinschaft
wir tun alles um so schnell wie möglich
aus dieser wahnsinnig zementierten
abhängigkeit fossile energien in die uns
die fehlentscheidungen der letzten
jahren gebracht haben rauszukommen auch
das ist wichtig und notwendig und wir
sind bei allem was wir tun vom festen
grundsatz geleitet dass die ukraine nach
der charta der vereinten nationen ein
uneingeschränktes recht auf
selbstverteidigung hat wir nehmen unsere
aufgabe verantwortungsvoll war
einerseits nicht kriegspartei zu werden
und das ist die erklärte absicht nicht
nur deutschland sondern aller
europäischen partnerinnen und partner
und andererseits die ukraine nicht
schutzlos diesem aggressor putin
auszuliefern liefern und hier genau
steht unsere verantwortung im
spannungsfeld immer wieder jeden tag
aufs neue zu entscheiden was ist
notwendig zu tun um die ukraine in ihrem
recht auf selbstverteidigung zu
unterstützen meine damen und herren und
da
deshalb ist es auch wichtig und
notwendig dass wir jetzt neben der
finanziellen humanitären und
waffenlieferungen die wir schon direkt
im anschluss getroffen haben nachdem
angriffs kriegsbeginn jetzt auch den
ringtausch schwerer waffen und die
massive finanzielle unterstützung der
ukraine für direkte waffenkäufe und die
lieferung eigener schwerer waffen da wo
es möglich ist zu prüfen in aller
sorgfalt und dann auch zu entscheiden so
wie wir das jetzt getan haben und in
diesem antrag noch einmal gemeinsam
bekräftigen die ukraine kann sich auf
unsere unterstützung verlassen
meine damen und herren es freut mich das
signal heute gemeinsamen singen von der
union abgeben auch dass an dieser stelle
ganz eindeutig gesagt in richtung der
cdu csu den ein wichtiges signal in
dieser krisenzeit ist nach innen und
nach außen das demokratinnen und
demokraten hier in diesem haus an dieser
stelle zusammen stehen und dafür bin ich
dankbar das hatte der bundesregierung
meine damen und herren und unser
gemeinsamer antrag heute hier im
parlament
sind ein starkes signal an die ukraine
bitte meine damen und herren
verstehen sie es als solches und es ist
auch ein klares signal an die menschen
hier im land die voller sorge auf das
leid die zerstörung und die entwicklung
dieses krieges schauen vielen dank
für die unionsfraktion ad aisch das wort
den kollegen friedrich merz
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
diesen jungs und mädels muss ich mal
sagen
weil ich nicht tue was ihr wollt deshalb
führe ich
so hat sich der bundeskanzler einige
tage vor ostern in einem
rundfunkinterview auf die frage ein
gelassen ob er und wie er denn in diesem
land führen mit jungs und mädels waren
dabei offenbar die drei
ausschussvorsitzenden gemeint die eine
reise in die west ukraine
unternommen hatten mal ganz unabhängig
davon wer das war mitglieder des
deutschen bundestages
herablassend mit jungs und mädels zu
bezeichnen das ist auch für einen
bundeskanzler der bundesrätlichen
vorschlag
und alle sangen herren einfach nur das
gegenteil von dem zu tun was mitglieder
des deutschen bundestages für richtig
halten ist auch kein ausdruck vom
führung
dieser sprachgebrauch ist eher ein
zeichen von unsicherheit und von
schwäche der bundeskanzler der
bundeskanzler hat über wochen die
diskussion über die frage ob der ukraine
denn nun waffen geliefert werden sollten
oder nicht hingehalten offengelassen
ausweichend beantwortet ich erinnere nur
an die
regierungsbefragung die wir vor drei
wochen hier hatten der bundeskanzler hat
alle fragen beantwortet die ihm nicht
gestellt worden sind und keine einzige
frage von denen beantwortet die wir im
gestellt hat meine damen
das sind
das ist nicht besonnenheit wie sie es in
den ampel fraktionen versuchen in den
letzten tagen zu erklären das ist zögern
das ist zaudern und das ist
ängstlichkeit nun regen sie sich darüber
auf dass
wir hier das im plenum ansprechen aber
meine damen und herren das problem für
den bundeskanzler war und ist nicht die
opposition das problem für den
bundeskanzler war und ist bis zum
heutigen tag die kritik aus den eigenen
reihen
und dabei waren dabei waren worte wie
führungsschwäche und kommunikations
desaster noch harmlose formulierungen
politische hütchen spiele sind im
bundeskanzler vorgeworfen worden bis hin
zu der offenen frage ob er denn seinem
amt noch gewachsen sei ich will es dabei
bewenden das ist gut
[Applaus]
also wenn sie wenn sie
staatspolitische verantwortung der
opposition nur so verstehen dass wir
ihnen in allem was sie hier vorlegen und
vorschlagen kritiklos zustimmen dann ist
das ein großer irrtum eine damen unter
und wir erlauben uns hier schon
wir erlauben uns hier schon diese kritik
die geäußert aufzunehmen und zum
gegenstand auf einer parlamentarischen
diskussion zu machen meine damen und
herren und es ist trotzdem gut dass wir
heute gemeinsam den versuch unternehmen
einen entschließungsantrag zu
verabschieden der sich umfassend mit der
hilfe für die ukraine gefasst wenn die
bundesregierung in wenn die
bundesregierung in den letzten tagen und
wochen zu diesen fragen eine klare und
einvernehmliche haltung eingenommen
hätte und wenn der bundeskanzler hat
dies hier klar und unmissverständlich
gesagt hätte dann wäre weder der antrag
notwendig gewesen noch diese ganze
debatte heute macht
und wie wir und wenn wir in der letzten
woche nicht einen antrag vorgelegt
hätten dann wären sie doch nie auf den
gedanken gekommen nun ihrerseits tätig
zu werden und einen solchen ansatz den
großen bundestag
mit ihren hier eine wir führen hier eine
wichtige diskussion und wir nehmen hier
auch unsere verantwortung in dieser
diskussion war und ich will deswegen
ich will ihnen nochmal auch zu der
debatte von gestern ihr etwas sagen wir
hatten gestern die diskussion über das
100 milliarden programm für die
bundeswehr und dem dazu vorgeschlagene
text der änderung des grundgesetzes
meine damen und herren wir haben die
sechs punkte die für uns wichtig sind
wenn wir dem denn dann zustimmen sollen
genannt ich sage ihnen nochmal nehmen
sie das bitte nicht auf die leichte
schulter wir sind grundsätzlich bereit
mit ihnen einen solchen weg zu gehen
aber wir lassen uns auch nicht einfach
nur so zur zustimmung auf fordern wir
haben einige punkte genannt und ich will
es hier an dieser stelle noch einmal
sehr deutlich wiederholen unsere
zustimmung ist auch davon abhängig dass
wir in wenigen jahren nicht wieder da
stehen wo wir heute stehen nämlich mit
einer unterfinanzierten bundeswehr und
deswegen blockiert
deswegen wollen wir sehen
dass der bund das der einzelplan 14 für
die verteidigung kontinuierlich
aufwächst und nicht die einmalig ein
bestimmter betrag zur verfügung gestellt
wird wir wollen die beschaffungs
systematik ändern übrigens der
bundeskanzler war begeistert als wir
ihnen das vorgeschlagen haben dass wir
an diesem beschaffungs system etwas
ändern wollen dann machen wir es doch
jetzt gemeinsam und nervösen und kippen
führen sie doch nicht ständig an der
opposition herum
diese beiden punkte nennen wir haben
hier noch einen ziemlich langen weg wir
haben hier noch einen ziemlich langen
weg vor uns und es sind dem vorschlag
den der bundeskanzler vor acht wochen
unternommen hat wertvolle zeit
verstrichen wir sind zu keinem dieser
punkte bisher überein gekommen
geschweige denn dass wir hier ein
gemeinsames gesamtkonzern voraus die
formuliert und aufgeschrieben haben wir
sind noch ziemlich weit entfernt von
einer einigung meine damen und herren
mit dem entschließungsantrag des
heutigen tages sind wir
dankenswerterweise einen schritt weiter
richtigerweise enthält dieser text nicht
nur bewertungen und einschätzungen zu
waffenlieferungen
richtigerweise auch wir wissen dass
waffengewalt in einer solchen
auseinandersetzung immer nur das letzte
mittel sein darf und letztendlich auch
das eingeständnis des scheiterns von
diplomatie und der suche nach
politischen lösungen umfasst das ist so
aber an dieser stelle stehen wir seit
dem 24 februar 2022 und ich will es mal
mit diesen worten deutlich sagen niemand
von uns befürwortet leichtfertig den
einsatz militärischer gewalt niemand wir
alle wissen
das mit dem einsatz von waffen
also diese zwischenrufe verstehe ich nun
wirklich überhaupt nicht wenn wir hier
eine wenn wir hier eine gewissenhafte
diskussion führen wollen und bei einem
solchen satz von ihnen solche solche
zwischenrufe kommen dann frage ich mich
wie ernst sie eigentlich wirklich die
bereitschaft hier vortragen mit uns zu
einer gemeinsamen lösung in diesen
schwierigen zeiten
wir haben doch alle diese wir haben doch
alle diese schrecklichen bilder vor
augen und sie beschweren uns doch jeden
tag die bilder dieser
menschenrechtsverletzung die bilder aus
diesen aus diesem kraftwerk aus diesem
stahlwerk da einmal in mario pohl das
sind doch furchtbare bilder aber gerade
weil wir diese bilder vor augen haben
müssen wir doch heute sagen einem
aggressor wie putin und seine
machtapparat muss man dann in einer
solchen situation auch als ultima ratio
mit militärischer gewalt begegnen es
geht nicht anders in einer solchen
situation eher als bestreitet niemand
aber wir müssen doch gemeinsam auch nach
draußen und erklären warum wir heute zu
einem solchen entschließungsantrag hier
gemeinsam kommen und wenn sie das schon
vor einigen wochen getan hätten noch mal
dann brauchen wir es doch heute
gemeinsam nicht zu tun an der stelle
stehen wir doch heute wenn die und ihre
mutige armee das nicht täten und wenn
wir der ukraine dabei nicht helfen
würden dann wird diese unterlassene
hilfe wie schon in der vergangenheit als
schwäche und als zögerlichkeit ausgelegt
und dann wird es nach der ukraine
weitere länder und weitere regionen
geben die von diesem regime bedroht
meine damen in diesem zusammen in diesem
zusammenhang ist der hinweis des
bundeskanzlers dass unsere deutschen
waffen möglicherweise einen dritten
weltkrieg auslösen würden ebenso
unverantwortlich wie aus unserer eigenen
historischen erfahrungen heraus falsch
und irreführend
der hinweis ist unverantwortlich
der hinweis ist unverantwortlich denn er
lässt ja nur den schluss zu dass aus der
sicht des bundeskanzlers alle anderen
länder die mehr für die ukraine tun als
wir und davon gibt es viele die
kriegsgefahr in europa erhöhen meine
damen und herren das ist doch eine
geradezu groteske umkehrung von ursache
und verantwortung für diesen krieg eine
rote oder
unerfahren
doch wenn wir erst richtig zur spd oder
warum sollten gerade deutsche waffen
diese wirkung haben alle anderen aber
nicht auf meine damen und herren der
historie der hinweis ist auch historisch
falsch weil doch gerade wir wissen dass
besänftigung und beschwichtigung in der
internationalen sprache der politik
heißt das appeasement die ausweitung
einer aggression überhaupt erst möglich
macht und deshalb ist es gut deshalb ist
es gut dass wir heute mit diesem
gemeinsamen antrag und der
beschlussfassung darüber klarheit
schaffen die deutsche bundesregierung
kann sich ab heute auf ein breites
zustimmendes votum des deutschen
bundestages stützen und der ukraine die
waffen liefern die sie braucht und die
wir dann auch zur verfügung stellen
können und deswegen will ich es
abschließend sagen und da hatte ich will
hier abschließend sagen ich will mich
ausdrücklich bedanken bei den fraktionen
der spd der grünen und der fdp und bei
ihren jeweiligen vorsitzenden dass wir
in den letzten tagen zu dieser
gemeinsamen haltung hier auch gefunden
haben die arbeit an den texten und die
vielen gespräche die wir in den letzten
tagen dazu geführt haben meine damen und
herren hat sich gelohnt herzlichen dank
das ding während das wort für die spd
fraktion
wow
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
seit über zwei monaten führt wladimir
putin einen brutalen angriffskrieg gegen
die ukraine täglich sehen wir das leid
dass putin und seine vasallen über die
menschen im land bringen gezielte tötung
von zivilisten die bombardierung von
krankenhäusern von schulen von
kindergärten
wladimir putin trägt die verantwortung
für diesen krieg er wird als
kriegsverbrecher in die geschichte
eingehen und wir werden alles daran
setzen dass er vor den zuständigen
gerichten dieser welt für diesen
brutalen krieg zu verantworten
es ist gut
es ist gut dass wir heute hier im
parlament ein eindeutiges ein um
missverständnisse und missverständliches
signal aus der mitte des deutschen
bundestages setzen putin muss diesen
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg
beenden wir stehen an der seite
derjenigen die mutig und tapfer in der
ukraine kämpfen wir stehen an der seite
der ukraine das machen wir mit diesem
gemeinsamen antrag deutlich
herr merz mir war wichtig diesen punkt
am anfang meiner rede zu nehmen bei
ihnen
bei ihnen hat es
erinnert es fünf minuten gedauert bis
sie zum ersten mal etwas zum krieg und
zum leiden der menschen in der ukraine
gesagt habe und ich habe mir eigentlich
auf meinem zettel draufstehen ich habe
hier eigentlich auf meinem zettel
draufstehen dank an die union weil herr
merz und ich muss ihnen das in aller
emotionalität auch sagen das hätte heute
eine staatspolitische rede von ihnen
werden können es ist aber
das ist eine parteipolitische rede
sofort sie haben
sie haben zu ihren eigenen leuten
gesprochen und ich will ihnen sagen herr
merz ich bin dankbar dafür dass wir
einen gemeinsamen antrag auf den weg
gebracht haben einen dank an die vier
fraktionen und die vorsitzenden
aber hier ist kein platz für
parteipolitische profilierung und ich
will dass
ich will dass
im ernst ich will dass aus meiner
eigenen geschichte beschreiben ich bin
2009 in dieses parlament gekommen die
spd es damals in die opposition gegangen
das war schwierig für uns wie lange
regiert haben wir haben eine schwarz
gelbe regierung erlebt die nicht immer
harmonisch worden und trotzdem haben wir
als spd damals bei den großen
internationalen fragen die abgestimmt
wurden nach dem prinzip gehandelt erst
das land dann die partei erinnern sie
sich erinnern sie sich herr merz
erinnern sie sich an das kleid das
gefecht das erste mal dass deutsche
soldaten im ausland gefallen sind
trotzdem hat die spd am afghanistan
mandat festgehalten hat das klare
bekenntnis zur bundeswehr abgegeben
erinnern sie sich an die großen debatten
über die schutzschirme für griechenland
für spanien der euro rettungsschirm wir
hätten uns das einfach machen können
aber wir haben damals nie gegen die
regierung gestimmt lieber herr merz und
ich habe mir sorgen gemacht die letzten
tage um die union als sie kritisiert
haben als sie kritisiert haben als je
kritisiert haben dass olaf scholz nach
japan fährt das olaf scholz sich mit
einem der wichtigsten westlichen
verbündeten trifft da ich mich gefragt
was ist nur aus der union von angela
merkel geworden was passiert da gerade
in
wie bei merck
lieber im märz diejenigen die am antrag
mitgeschrieben haben die haben nach dem
prinzip gehandelt erst das land dann die
partei und ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
diejenigen die ihre rede geschrieben
haben auch nach diesem grundsatz die
räder aufgestiegen
aber zur sache
zur sache und ich will ein paar sätze
ein paar sätze zu diesem antrag auf
sagen weil es mir weil es mir wirklich
wichtig ist dieser antrag stützt das
handeln der bundesregierung diese
regierung handelt sie liefert sie führt
und ich will dass an dieser stelle auch
sagen weil antragsberatung
antragsberatung auch einen moment sind
wo man mal danke sagen kann die
vertreterinnen und vertretern der
bundesregierung haben entscheidungen zu
treffen von einer reichweite für die
nächsten 10 15 20 jahren von einer
tragweite die über leben und tod geht es
sind entscheidungen die man sich nicht
einfach macht in der regierung und ich
will stellvertretend hier nancy faeser
christian lindner annalena baerbock
christine lambrecht robert habeck und
vor allem bundeskanzler olaf scholz
danken für das was wir in den letzten
wochen an guter führung durch die
bundesregierung gemeinsam erlebt
und weil ich
und weil ich in den letzten tagen ja
viel doch in bewertungen der
bundesregierung gelesen habe übrigens
ich empfehle mal die aktuelle ausgabe
der times da kriegt man mal einen
überblick auf wie deutschlands rolle in
der welt gesehen wird lassen sie uns mal
auf die fakten schauen fakt eins
deutschland hat mit den partnern
sanktionen vorbereitet und setzt diese
massiv durch selten gab es ein so großes
umfassendes sanktionspaket wie jetzt
gegen russland russland wird ökonomisch
abgekoppelt von den internationalen
märkten und wird das über einen langen
zeitraum bitter zu spüren bekommen was
die konsequenzen dieser sanktionen sind
fakt 2 deutschland reduziert die
abhängigkeit von russischem gas und
russischem öl und das tun wir in einem
größeren tempo als es im
koalitionsvertrag schon angelegt war und
ich bin dankbar dafür dass wir das
gemeinsam jetzt in aller entschiedenheit
auch täglich tun fakten nummer drei ist
dass wir eingebettet in die
internationale kooperation agieren der
westen war lange nicht mehr so geeint
und so stark wie jetzt die nato die
europäische union und sagt ja auch da
müssen wir was draus machen wir können
nicht nur zusammen kommen weil putin uns
treibt sondern wir brauchen jetzt eine
transatlantische agenda für die zukunft
wir brauchen jetzt eine starke
europäische union das ist ein geschenk
was da ist aber es ist das handeln der
bundesregierung
und ja deutschland liefert waffen diese
bundesregierung hat mit einem prinzip
gebrochen das über jahrzehnte in
deutschland galt wir liefern seit dem
beginn des krieges und wir sind jeden
tag einen schritt weiter gegangen in der
qualität in der quantität dessen was wir
tun aber wir hatten auch hier prinzipien
und in dieser kontinuität stehen auch
die entscheidung der letzten tage wir
haben gesagt wir stimmen uns ab mit den
internationalen partnern wir haben
gesagt wir gefährden nicht die eigene
landes und bündnisverteidigung und wir
haben gesagt dass wir selbst nicht zur
kriegspartei werden alles das tut die
bundesregierung und ich bin dankbar
dafür und das ist mein letzter punkt der
nicht ansprechen will ich bin dankbar
dafür dass wir eine regierung haben die
weiß dass sie konsequent und schnell
entscheiden muss die aber nichts herr
merz sowie das manchmal bei ihnen der
eindruck ist morgens aufwacht und
überlegt was können wir heute tun gerade
in diesen zeiten gerade in zeiten von
leben und tod von krieg und frieden geht
es darum dass man grundüberzeugung und
prinzipien hat und die auch in einer
zeitenwende nicht über den haufen wirft
liebe
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
trotz aller parteipolitische differenzen
will ich dass sie am ende noch mal
betonen es ist richtig und wichtig dass
es hier aus der mitte des parlamentes
ein klares signal an wladimir putin ein
klares signal an die menschen in der
ukraine gibt dass wir auf der richtigen
seite der geschichte als deutscher
bundestag stehen aber ich sage ihnen
auch ein kleingeist und eine
kleinkariertheit wie sie manches mal
gerade erlebt wird in der politischen
debatte das bringt uns nicht weiter wir
haben schwierige entscheidungen vor uns
beispielsweise mit dem sondervermögen
und herr merz ist es mein letzter appell
machen sie deutlich dass sie an der
seite der soldatinnen und soldaten
stehen machen sie deutlich kleiner
vorher waren sie deutlich dass sich dass
das entdecken sind
geführt der verteidigungsministerium
dass sie bereit sind diese fehler zu
korrigieren und mit der ampel gemeinsam
daran arbeiten dass wir die bundeswehr
ausstatten das wäre ein wichtiges signal
aus der union fehler passieren
tino köhler hat das wort für die
fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren liebe landsleute
vor nunmehr über zwei monaten hat
russland die ukraine angegriffen und wir
haben wieder krieg in europa
noch zu beginn haben wir alle hier in
diesem hohen haus gehofft dass der
konflikt schnell beendet sein wird und
die bevölkerung in der ukraine wieder in
ruhe leben kann leider kam es anders die
fraktion gedenkt aller kriegstoten und
trauert mit den hinterbliebenen
[Applaus]
der neue krieg in europa stellt uns alle
vor eine schwierige situation und
entscheidung letztlich werden alte
wunden aufgerissen und überkommene
denkmuster bedient aber gerade für ein
friedliches zusammenleben müssen wir die
ideologischen scheuklappen absetzen und
uns der diskussion im eigenen land
stellen ich finde es ganz dem
unentschuldbar dass bundeskanzler oder
scholz heute an so einem wichtigen tag
hier nicht anwesend ist bislang stand
der bereits zu seinem wort dass waffen
keine lösung sind und heute bringen die
koalition und die unionsfraktion einen
gemeinsamen antrag ein der den ukraine
krieg verlängern wird und unser
kriegsparteien ein atomar geführten
krieg machen könnte wer die kollegen wir
streiten über die zukunft deutschlands
es geht um krieg und frieden auch in
mitteleuropa und herr scholz reis der
kirschblüte nach japan und nein auch
reisepläne kann man ändern erinnern sie
sich der bundeskanzler liess
aussenministerin berbalk vorfristig nach
berlin zurückkehren um für die
impfpflicht abzustimmen und da sieht man
eigentlich
die prioritäten dieses bundeskanzlers wo
sind die und alle die immer davon
sprechen aus der geschichte gelernt zu
haben sind heute die ersten die uns
aktiven ein krieg hineinziehen wollen
und genau das sagt und bezeichnet diese
vorliegende antrag er liest sich wie die
beitritts begründung zu einem krieg vom
duktus her erinnert er an die dunkelsten
zeiten
und ich musste hier noch mal deutlich
sagen ich muss noch mal deutlich sagen
wir befinden uns nicht im krieg mit
russland oder irgendeinem land und die
große mehrheit der deutschen bevölkerung
möchte nicht in diesem krieg und an
diesem krieg beteiligt werden
und deswegen muss man fragen welchen
zweck verfolgen sie die ukraine gehört
nicht der nato an auch nicht der eu und
ist ebenso ein souveräner staaten
europas wie russland es liegt im
deutschen interesse auch zukünftig zu
beiden staaten ein gutes verhältnis zu
unterhalten politisch wirtschaftlich und
kulturell
von thun
mit der entscheidung der bundesregierung
gebe panzer an die ukraine zu liefern
wurde die position deutschlands
entschieden geschwächt denn wir können
nicht mehr als neutraler vermittler
auftreten und nur noch eigentlich hoffen
dass dieses vorgehen die diplomatischen
wege nicht endgültig versperrt hat sie
intervenieren mit waffenlieferungen
einen fremden krieg und nennen das werte
geleitete außenpolitik haben sich
eigentlich mal gefragt welche wirkung
diese entscheidung auf unsere partner
china und indien macht wir brauchen
interessengeleitete außenpolitik für
deutschland und europa
die fraktion der alternative für
deutschland im bundestag spricht sich
ganz entschieden gegen die lieferung von
waffen an die ukraine aus waffen haben
kriege noch nie verkürzt und sind keine
humanitären hilfsgütern
wir haben und wir müssen unsere
humanitäre hilfe fortführen und ich
meine damit die arbeit die unterstützung
auch von kriegsflüchtlingen wie die
hilfe für die notleidenden vor zum
beispiel durch die lieferung
medizinischer hilfsmittel medikamente
sowie die möglichkeit sauberes wasser
und energie bereitzustellen und viele
hier im plenarsaal an gerade auch die
medien müssen endlich rhetorisch
abrüsten die friedens rhetorik muss in
den vordergrund treten nicht die
kriegsrhetorik
werte kollegen
wer die kollegen bitte kommen sie zur
vernunft lassen sie ihre gewissen
entscheiden und stimmen sie gegen die
waffenlieferung an die ukraine die
alternative für deutschland sie ist die
einzige fraktion im deutschen bundestag
die aktiv für den frieden auf dem
kontinent europa
fielen
[Applaus]
der kollegen christian dürr hat das wort
für die fdp fraktion
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
kollegen seit über zwei monaten herrscht
bereits krieg in der ukraine und damit
gegen einen freien staat gegen freie
menschen gegen die freiheit an sich man
darf nicht müde werden zu sagen dieser
krieg ist mit nichts zu rechtfertigen
das ist ein angriffskrieg russland gegen
das völkerrecht gegen jegliche humanität
und wir müssen diesen krieg verurteilen
an jedem tag in jeder stunde wird dürfen
uns an die bilder aus der ukraine nicht
gewöhnen meine tante
dass russland zivilisten die flucht aus
umkämpften gebieten die mario pohl nicht
erlaubt ist eine schande und putin muss
wissen die ganze welt wie die
kriegsverbrechen die die russische seite
täglich begehrt wir werden als
deutschland als westen wir werden die
kriegsverbrecher zur rechenschaft ziehen
diebe kollegen kollegen
putting führt krieg gegen die ukraine
und damit gegen die liberale demokratie
deshalb ist es eben auch im
sicherheitspolitischen interesse
deutschlands dass die ukraine diesen
krieg nicht verliert deshalb müssen wir
jetzt alles tun was wir können um die
ukraine bei diesem ziel zu unterstützen
meine damen und herren und dafür steht
der antrag aus der mitte des hauses an
diesem tag
und
herr kollege merz mit gc nicht mit dem
kollegen lars klingbeil das war mir
wichtig vorab zu sagen ich bin dankbar
dafür dass die cdu csu fraktion sich
bereit erklärt hat dem
antragsentwurf der regierungsfraktion
beizutreten das ist ein wichtiges signal
heute das anerkenne und wertschätze ich
der kollege merz ich will übrigens daran
erinnern
die erste reaktion des kollegen frei war
es glaube ich der sagte dieser antrag
ist zu lang wie immer bei der ampel erst
viel zu unkonkret jetzt hat er aus sicht
des fraktions 14 genau die richtige
länge und spricht die richtigen punkte
an ja man kann dazulernen darüber freut
sich die ampel regierungsfraktion herr
kollege merz und ich will ich will eins
dazu sagen weil das thema sondervermögen
hier angesprochen worden ist und es war
gestern thema debatte und das legitim
ist auch hier zum gegenstand zu machen
ich stelle mir eine sekunde vor die
oppositionsfraktionen aus bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp hätten bei viel kleineren
themen in der vergangenen woche sowie
den digital pakt für schulen oder dem
thema grundsteuer gesagt wir reden mit
den regierungsfraktionen nur unter der
prämisse dass wir keine aller
abgeordneten wenn die abstimmung
schicken als zur zwei-drittel-mehrheit
fehlen wie kleinteilig wäre das schon
damals bei diesen kleinen themen gewesen
herr merz ich fordere sie auf an dieser
wichtigen stelle weiter debatte um das
sondervermögen ihre strategie zu ändern
im sicherheitspolitischen interesse
deutschland und gerade auch im interesse
der ukraine herr merz sie müssen ihre
strategie ändern und endlich sagen dass
sie dabei sein wollen als gesamte cdu
csu bundestagsfraktion klagt kommst doch
keine andere antwort und vermeidung
gegen herr kollege
meine damen und herren es geht um die
rolle deutschlands in dieser krise und
darum was wir konkret tun können und
gemeinsam mit unseren partner die
ukraine bestmöglich zu unterstützen
vor diesem hintergrund ist es der
richtige schritt waffenlieferung zu
ermöglichen sowohl direkte als auch
indirekte lieferung durch unsere partner
und uns setzt es ist richtig ich will
das aussprechen es ist richtig schwere
waffen in diese lieferung mit
einzubeziehen russland hat die ukraine
überfallen mit einem vielfachen an
militärgerät fünfmal so viele panzer
dreimal so viele aktive soldaten die
ukraine befindet sich in einem krieg auf
offenen boden und es geht um ganz
konkrete gelände gewinnen denn wir haben
gesehen was das bedeutet meine damen und
herren roger ist kein einzelfall jeder
russische vorstoß bedeutet dass sich
diese verbrechen wiederholen die
lieferung schwerer waffen ist natürlich
lasting ball hat es gesagt keine
selbstverständlichkeit aber es ist jetzt
eine notwendigkeit meine damen und
herren
und
dabei sollten wir
an zwei prämissen uns orientieren wir
liefern die art waffen die auch andere
verbündete liefern wir liefern was
unsere eigene bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit nicht gefährdet
und deshalb liefern wir jetzt was die
ukraine braucht um das in einen kontext
zu stellen die vereinigten staaten
frankreich
großbritannien und andere haben schon
oder planen die konkrete lieferung
schwerer waffen wir stehen also mit
diesem schritt eng
an der seite unserer partner deutschland
muss seiner verantwortung gerecht werden
und das drückt dieser gemeinsame antrag
gemeinsame antrag aus der mitte des
deutschen bundestages heute aus meine
damen und herren
und ich will zum schluss 1 sagen was
eine wichtige stop präsidentin putin hat
mit seinem angriffs trägt die alte
weltordnung zerrissen das alte kommt
nicht wieder deshalb werden die auch die
wirtschaftlichen beziehungen mit putins
russland beenden und wir werden die
beziehung zu liberalen demokratien
weltweit stärken deshalb ist es richtig
dass der bundeskanzler dieser tage nach
japan gereist ist um genau das zu tun
auch das will ich an dieser stelle sagen
ich bin dem bundeskanzler ausdrücklich
dankbar das ist genau das was er genau
dass es
ist die letzte sache denn es ist ein
wichtiges zeichen dass wir heute einen
antrag beraten der von der großen
demokratischen mitte des hauses getragen
wird und am ende auch beschlossen wird
deutschland meine damen und herren steht
an der seite der
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
gemeinsam mit seinen verbündeten und
partnern in der welt ich danke ihnen
[Applaus]
die partner das wort für die fraktion
die linke
werde meine damen und herren es klar und
deutlich zu sagen meine fraktion
verurteilt auf das schärfste den
brutalen und völkerrechtswidrigen krieg
den putin führt ohne wenn und aber
meine damen und herren der bundeskanzler
hat am vergangenen wochenende gegenüber
dem spiegel interview gegeben und hat
seinen bisherigen kurs dort verteidigt
keine schweren waffen in die ukraine zu
liefern ich darf seine begründung
zitieren ich tue alles um eine
eskalation zu verhindern die zu einem
dritten weltkrieg führt es darf keinen
atomkrieg
millionen menschen in deutschland haben
genau diese sorgen und ängste und meine
fraktion unterstützt dass ausdrücklich
und das sollte auch richtschnur ihrer
politik sein meine damen
unter anderem mit der angst vor kritik
hat der bundeskanzler die lieferung
schwerer waffen ausgeschlossen und zwar
zu recht
bei damen und herren und deswegen
verstehe ich überhaupt nicht das 72
stunden später die verteidigungsminister
und das gegenteil verkündet deutschland
liefert schwere waffen in die ukraine
meine damen und herren das heißt jeden
tag eine kehrtwende ich komme da nicht
mehr mit und es geht vielen menschen in
unserem land so dass sie dann nicht mehr
mitkommen wir leben erleben ein
kommunikations desaster der ampel ist
dass die führung her klingbeil die olaf
scholz versprochen hat und bei die man
bei ihm bestellen kann sie haben die
schattenminister hofreiter und strack
zimmermann die führende parallel
diplomatie das ist die lage der ampel
wenn ich den antrag lese muss ich muss
ich dem bundeskanzler es tut mir leid
die jungs und mädels die haben sich
tatsächlich durchgesetzt das ist die
wahrheit und in ihrem antrag machen sie
jetzt sogar china mit zu einer
konfliktpartei wollen sie wirklich damit
etwa für frieden sorgen wenn sich china
in dem antrag aufhören nein das ist das
gegenteil das tut doch genau das jetzt
was anderes gewollt habe dass vier tage
nach dem spiegel interview ein antrag
vorliegt der im widerspruch zu seinen
aussagen steht das ist kein ausweis von
führungsstärke das ist das gegenteil
meine damen und jetzt aber auch zu ihnen
hat sie haben wir hier so nachdrücklich
ihre position verteidigt was die seit
tagen hier aufgeführt haben das ist ein
schauspiel das hat mit verantwortung
ehrlich gesagt nichts zu tun das ist der
situation völlig unangemessen und im
übrigen schade das dem ansehen
deutschland weil sie ja genau das
befördern nämlich die spaltung sie haben
die drei doch erpresst mit ihrer
zustimmung zu dem 100 milliarden paket
das ist doch deswegen gibt es doch den
antrag und setzte jedoch überhaupt nicht
gegeben dass es letztlich putin spiel
ihnen geht es nicht um die ukraine ihn
geht es um profilierung und
innenpolitischen geländegewinn gerade
mit blick auf die wahlen in schleswig
holstein und nordrhein westfalen und das
ist inakzeptabel meine damen und herren
wir die fragestellung an welchem punkt
wir haben jetzt eigentlich sind lieber
rolf mützenich sie haben davon
gesprochen völlig zu recht dass es eine
militärische schlagseite ja das ist
sogar meine sache etwas untertrieben es
gibt einen fatalen wettlauf höher
schneller weiter wer liefert die
schwersten waffen glauben sie wirklich
irgend wer hier im hause das mit der
lieferung schwerer waffen dieser krieg
beendet wird was ist denn eigentlich das
strategische ziel von deutschland was
ist denn eigentlich das strategische
ziel der ukraine das wäre nochmal die
voraussetzung dass zu wissen bevor man
liefert warum liefern eigentlich nicht
die amerikaner modernstes kriegsgerät
das müssen sie doch denn eigentlich
machen wenn das so eindeutig wer nein
hier wird viel zu wenig über
diplomatische vorstöße und initiativen
gretel heeres waren moskaus orientiert
das sollte eine rolle spielen da sollte
es unterstützung geben meine damit dass
sie mich zurückkommen auch die aussage
des bundeskanzlers ich tue alles um eine
eskalation zu verhindern die einen zu
einem dritten weltkrieg führt es darf
keinen atomkrieg geben ja meine damen
und herren das erwarten die menschen das
erwarten die menschen auch von der
bundesregierung und das muss das oberste
ziel sein in dieser dramatischen
entwicklung denn darauf haben sie ihren
amtseid geschworen und ich hoffe dass
das was sie gesagt haben wir hatten
prinzipien der klingbeil dass das
wirklich ein versprecher war dieser
krieg putins muss schnellstmöglich enden
er darf sich nicht ausweiten aber
solidarität mit der ukraine mit den
menschen und karine einerseits
deeskalation und jegliche jegliche
diplomatische bemühungen andererseits
das sind zwei seiten einer medaille
schwere waffen zu liefern bitte das
macht vielen menschen angst meine damen
und herren und deswegen werden wir uns
auch dagegen positionieren herzlichen
dank
die kollegen hier starb ohga hat das
wort für bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
jeder und jede von uns mit herz und
verstand will doch nur eins dass diese
blutige gewalt gegen die unschuldigen
menschen in der ukraine endlich sofort
auf
er wollte lieber sanktionsdrohung gab es
vor dem 24 februar mit dem ziel diesen
krieg zu verhindern wie viele harte
sanktionen nach dem beginn des
angriffskriegs damit es zu einem ende
der gewalt kommt all das war zwar
richtig und notwendig hat wladimir putin
aber bisher nicht unmittelbar gestoppt
das einzige was ihnen auffällt noch mehr
kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit zu verüben das
einzige was zur befreiung bereits
besetzter gebiete beigetragen hat das
ist der entschiedener und mutige
widerstand der ukraine
die menschen dort verteidigen gerade mit
allem was sie haben ihr land ihr leben
und ihre sicherheit angesichts ihres
kampfes für frieden aber auch für unsere
sicherheit stehen auch wir in der
verantwortung
und ja es ist nie eine einfache
entscheidung tödliche waffen zu liefern
das darf es auch nicht sein aber in
diesen dramatischen wochen kann und darf
es auch keine falsche zurückhaltung
geben die den brutalen krieg kalkül
nichts entgegen zu setzen weiß
lassen sie mich an dieser stelle auch zu
allen sagen die mine waffenlieferungen
würden diesen krieg verlängert ein
militärischer sieg russlands bedeutet
kein ende der gewalt und keine befreiung
journalisten
die ganzen berichte über morde
misshandlungen der systematischen
vergewaltigung und weitere schwere
menschenrechtsverletzungen bewiesen
dafür stehen die toten von botschaft und
an vielen anderen orten in der ukraine
der plan von präsident putin ist eine
durchsetzung eigener imperialer
machtansprüche auf den trümmern der
ukraine mit jeder zerstörten stadt will
er seine position am verhandlungstisch
stärken deshalb ist eine unterstützung
der ukraine mit waffen und allem was
nötig ist auch die voraussetzung dafür
dass dieser krieg am ende auch mit
verhandlungen beendet werden kann die
nicht von russland diktiert werden
wenn eine solche vermeintliche
verhandlungslösung sie würde keinen
frieden sondern nun neue verbrechen
bringen und den weg für weitere
aggression und gewalt in der ukraine und
auf unserem kontinent bahnen dass meine
damen und herren sind die gründe warum
viele in diesem hohen haus die
unterstützung mit waffenlieferungen in
einer sehr schwierigen abwägung für
richtig halten und ich finde wir haben
heute auch in dieser debatte vielleicht
ein bisschen zu viel darüber gesprochen
wer wie was wo gesagt hat wer wie wo
aufgetreten ist und ich möchte mich ganz
herzlich bei allen kolleginnen und
kollegen in den ampel fraktionen aber
auch bei den kolleginnen und kollegen in
der union die anders aufgetreten sind
anders argumentiert haben als wir das
heute hier erlebt haben bedanken dass es
zu diesem starken zeichen der einigkeit
der solidarität mit der ukraine in
diesen dramatischen zeiten getroffen
in der botschaft ist dass unsere
solidarität mit der ukraine riesig ist
und dass russland diesen krieg mit
seinen verbrechen und seiner brutalität
nicht gewinnen darf mit dem ringtausch
und gelang mit deutscher unterstützung
schwere waffen schnell in den einsatz
der ukrainischen streitkräfte zugleich
müssen mit blick auf die lieferung
moderner und komplexere systeme die
länger brauchen jetzt entscheidungen und
vorbereitungen getroffen werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
verständlicherweise ist in den letzten
tagen viel über waffenlieferungen
diskutiert worden es ist eine schwierige
entscheidung aber es wäre falsch das
deutsche europäische engagement allein
auf die frage von waffenlieferungen zu
reduzieren es gehört so viel mehr dazu
eine diplomatie die alles für ein ende
der gewalt und das system putin iso
international isoliert alles mögliche
was wir tun können um das leid der
menschen zu lindern von der erhöhung der
humanitären hilfe bis zur psychosozialen
versorgung dass frauen die
vergewaltigung erlitten haben die
vorbereitung weiterer sanktionen die
aufklärung und verfolgung von
kriegsverbrechen und verbrechen gegen
die menschlichkeit die finanzielle
unterstützung der ukraine und eine
politische perspektive in der
europäischen union wie wir sie auch in
unserem antrag beschrieben
ebenso bereits die rückversicherung dass
schutz unserer mittel und
osteuropäischen partnerinnen und partner
aber auch der skandinavischen mit dazu
eine entwicklungszusammenarbeit die
versucht die folgen für den globalen
süden ab zumindest und besonders auf
eine energiepolitik die abhängigkeiten
verwundbarkeiten aber auch unseren
beitrag zur finanzierung des kreml
regimes massiv reduziert minister habe
hat vorgestern angekündigt das dach der
bereits drastischen reduzierung der
abhängigkeit von russischem öl in den
letzten wochen nun ein sehr baldiger und
deutlich schnellerer ausstieg möglich
ist und das ist ein sehr wichtiger
schritt von großer tragweite
meine damen und herren all das gehört zu
einem umfassenden ansatz dazu und am
ende zählt was ihr tun dass unsere
bundesregierung weiter entschlossen kann
so koling denn die menschen in der
ukraine brauchen in diesen düsteren
zeiten alle unterstützung die wir geben
können vielen dank
der kollege dr johann wadephul hat jetzt
das wort polizei suchen
[Applaus]
damen und herren spät kommt hier doch
ihr kommt möchte ich den kolleginnen und
kollegen der ampel koalition entgegen
rufen macht uns möglich heute dem antrag
zuzustimmen
wir stimmen dem antrag zu weil sie die
gretchenfrage die die geschichte
deutschland heute stellt richtig
beantworten deutschland steht
entschlossen an der seite der ukraine
und liefert schwere waffen
wir stehen zusammen und wir betonen die
gemeinsamkeit der demokratinnen und
demokraten hier in der mitte des hauses
und das tun wir
gerne das tun wir voller überzeugung und
insofern schließt sich an viele
äußerungen
der rednerinnen und redner der
koalitionsfraktionen hier an es ist
wichtig gerade in dieser zeit dass
deutschland ein bild der geschlossenheit
zeigt wir werfen putin diesen
angriffskrieg diesen vernichtungskrieg
nicht durchgehen lassen deutschland
steht geschlossen an der seite der
ukraine geschlossen an der seite der
alliierten die die ukraine hier
unterstützen und das ein signal der
humanität der menschlichkeit ein signal
für freiheit und für die friedensordnung
in europa das wichtig ist
und deswegen
deswegen
kollege bartsch will ich schon kollegen
der afg braucht man gar nicht darauf
eingehen sagen wir haben ein
strategisches ziel dabei und europa das
zusammensteht hat ein strategisches ziel
wir wollen putin stoppen wir wollen
nicht zu sehen wir einen genozid begeht
wie frauen vergewaltigt werden die
zivilisten getötet werden wie
flächenbombardements vorgenommen werden
und wie hier die friedensordnung europas
in einer art und weise zerstört wie wir
es uns vor weniger zeit nicht habe
vorstellen können und ich glaube das
wäre eigentlich ein ziel wo auch eine
linke partei
die ja mal auch den anspruch hatte für
frieden und völkerverständigung
einzustehen wo auch eine linke partei
darüber nachdenken sollte ob sie an
dieser stelle nicht wirklich auch an der
seite der freien ukraine stehen sollte
aus meiner sicht wäre das angebracht
ich halte es auch für richtig ist wird
deutsche bundestag darüber entscheidung
bin froh dass der deutsche bundestag
darüber entscheidet
manche äußerung als wir den antrag
angekündigt haben aus den reihen der
koalition habe ich nicht ganz verstanden
das sei parteipolitik grad von der fdp
parteipolitische ist boden tun dabei
haben wir doch ihren antrag den sie auf
dem bundesparteitag ein ziemlich
verabschiedet haben hier nur zur geltung
gebracht meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren stellen wir unser licht nicht
unter den scheffel nein es ist eine
schwierige ist eine abwägungsfrage aber
dass eine derartige frage ob deutschland
schwere waffen liefert gerade vom
höchsten beschlussgremium in einer
parlamentarischen demokratie auch
getroffen wird das muss doch alle
demokraten alle parlamentarier hier ein
das muss es uns doch wert dann ist doch
richtig dass der deutsche bundestag
darüber entscheidet und es ist gut dass
der deutsche bundestag darüber
entscheidet
und das will ich in allem respekt sagen
ich bin ein großer freund japans und es
ist richtig dass der bundeskanzler dahin
reist aber ich sage ihnen auch in dieser
historischen situation nach einer langen
osterpause nach dieser schwierigen
entscheidung wo er selber die frage
aufgeworfen hat ob es nicht einen
atomkrieg
hervorrufen könnte da ist es wäre es die
nicht nur der respekt gegenüber dem
hohen hause gewesen sondern da wäre es
seine verantwortung als bundeskanzler
olaf scholz gewesen deutschland und er
ist der kanzler dieses landes und der
welt zu erklären warum diese
entscheidung getroffen wird sie haben
von einer staatspolitischen rede
gesprochen erklingen bei die
staatspolitische rede hätte heute hier
der bundeskanzler halten müssen der wäre
hier gefordert gewesen den hätten wir
hier sehen wollen und wenn sie sagen
erst das land
erst das land und dann andere dinge dann
gilt das für alle und ich habe großen
respekt vor menschen die früher diese
regierung geführt haben aber dass
gerhard schröder sagt erst mein konto
und dann alles andere das ist ihre
aufgabe als parteivorsitzender der
aufzuräumen dafür zu sorgen dass das
beendet
dankeschön
der kollege dr nils schmid hat das wort
für die spd
frau präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren
schade schade erwartet gut ist auch so
eine gute rede bis zu bis auf ihrem
schluss
und ich will noch mal eins noch mal
sagen wegen der reise des bundeskanzlers
nach japan
japan ist in asien der wichtigste werte
partner deutschlands g7 mitglied wir
haben alle gemeinsam die letzte
bundesregierung dazu beglückwünscht eine
indopazifik strategie verabschiedet zu
haben und deshalb ist es gut dass die
erste asienreise des neuen
bundeskanzlers olaf scholz gerade nach
japan geht und dass wir damit auch ein
deutliches signal setzen wie wichtig uns
ja japan und asien insgesamt ist genauso
wie ich ist es wichtig dass die deutsch
indischen regierungskonsultationen
demnächst stattfinden und deshalb stehen
wir voll hinter dieser reise auch zu
diesem zeitpunkt
und historische und staatspolitische
reden kann man halten und im unterschied
zur unionsfraktion hat der kanzler mit
der zeitenwende regierungserklärung dies
schon geradezu reinig konflikt getan und
dass wir jetzt auf der strecke
hier im deutschen bundestag noch einmal
gemeinsam klar ziehen dass wir hinter
der ukraine hinter dem iranischen volk
stehen dass wir dazu einen gemeinsamen
antrag verabschieden ist ein unglaublich
starkes zeichen und ich will dann doch
herrn waren insbesondere noch einmal
danken dass er diese gemeinsamkeit
heraus gestrichen hat und setze darauf
dass für die dauer des konfliktes des
krieges aber auch für die langwierige
auseinandersetzung mit einem aggressiven
russland unter putin dass diese
gemeinsamkeit möglichst lange erhalten
bleibt dann ist auch ein gutes zeichen
dass die union jetzt dem
koalitionsantrag beitritt ihn
unterstützt wir haben sechs wörter
verändert aber ansonsten ist der
umfassende antrag der drei ampel
parteien die grundlage dieser
gemeinsamen breiten beschlussfassung
damit schließlich auch die union einem
umfassenden sicherheitsbegriff an wo es
eben nicht nur um waffenlieferungen geht
sondern auch in die internationale
ordnung die verteidigung des
völkerrechts die strafverfolgung von
kriegsverbrechen die auswirkungen auf
globale ernährungssicherheit die rolle
chinas in diesem konflikt all das ist in
diesen antrag zu recht aufgegriffen
worden und im ergebnis
unterstützt dieser antrag die sorgfältig
abwägen der politik der bundesregierung
des bundeskanzlers und deshalb sind
jegliche vorwürfe das zaudern und
führungsschwäche zu tage treten völlig
fehl am platz wie diesem antrag sind
diese vorwürfe hinfällig geworden eines
fairen rahmen
und mit diesem antrag bekennt sich die
große mehrheit des deutschen bundestages
auch zu den zwei tragenden prinzipien
der politik deutschlands
während des krieges russlands gegen die
ukraine die erste linie ist von der nato
schon sehr frühzeitig vor ausbruch des
krieges festgelegt worden die nato und
damit auch deutschland wird nicht
kriegspartei das ist ein leitprinzip das
auch jeden schritt diese bundesregierung
leitet und das zweite prinzip ist putin
darf diesen krieg nicht gewinnen
deshalb unterstützen wir diese freiheit
mit allem was wir zur verfügung haben
politisch diplomatisch ökonomisch und
natürlich auch sehr wohl abgewogen
militärisch
natürlich wollen wir alle möglichst bald
ein ende des krieges aber
dass sich auch richtung linkspartei
nicht um den preis dass der aggressor
gewinnt denn putin darf diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren und deshalb ist eben
jeder schritt auch der waffenlieferung
sorgfältig abzuwägen mit dem blick auf
die möglichkeit der eskalation und auf
die möglichkeit dass die nato durch
kriegspartei werden könnte und deshalb
ist auch kein drehbuch vorhanden gibt es
nicht eine einfache wahrheit in den
diskussionen die wir führen und deshalb
ist es so wichtig dass sehr vorsichtig
sehr ausgewogen entschieden wird durch
diejenigen die die verantwortung tragen
an erster linie die bundesregierung und
wir müssen das dilemma aus halten
dass der krieg erst dann und dann
besonders schnell zu ende geht wenn die
ukraine militärisch in die lage versetzt
wird eine kapitulation gegenüber putin
zu verhindern am netz angesprochen es
ist ein paradox auch ein dilemma das ein
schnelles ende des krieges voraussetzt
erstmal waffen zu liefern damit die
ukraine überhaupt in eine
verhandlungsposition kommt dass putin
nicht einseitig das ende krieges
diktieren kann damit müssen wir umgehen
das müssen wir aushalten das ist
schwierig meine damen und herren deshalb
ist es auch so wichtig dass bei den
militärischen entscheidungen so
sorgfältig abgewogen wird und damit
komme ich zum schluss sein bitte an uns
alle nicht nur an uns im parlament
sondern auch an die deutsche
gesellschaft und die medien an die
social media welt
diese debatte trägt uns um dieser trick
treffen sollen wir wollen durch reine
helfen aber es gibt eben keine einfachen
lösungen man kann nicht heute mal die
waffe aus dem internet ziehen und sagen
sie muss geliefert werden und morgen die
andere es ist eine wirklich wirklich
schwere und auch neuartige debatte in
deutschland in keinem anderen nato land
wird öffentlich über die details von
waffen liefern so ausgiebig diskutiert
wie in deutschland
nein das hat nichts mit uns zu tun so
etwas damit zu tun dass uns ist umtreibt
und das ist nicht einfach ist meines
laternen am turn und gerade weil es
nicht einfach ist verbiete es sich auch
nur einfach in twitter oder auch medial
zu meinen das ist die einzig der einzig
mögliche weg und deshalb wünsche ich mir
dass wir manche stilblüte manchen
überschießenden dieser drei ende der
debatte in zukunft vermeiden und dass
wir mit heißem herzen und kühlem kopf
diese debatte führen genauso wie der
bundeskanzler es tut meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren herzlichen
dank
für die fdp fraktion spricht auch der
anzünder golland
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
es ist immer ein undankbares geschäft
nach erklärungen für ein verhalten zu
suchen dass frauen und kinder tötet und
städte in schutt und asche legt und wenn
es außerdem noch um freiheit demokratie
und westliche werte geht muss man in
einem land wie deutschland
auf der richtigen seite der geschichte
stehen die moral schlägt immer die
geopolitik wissen wir doch seit langem
dass die nato als verteidigungsbündnis
ist und putin wenn er nicht angst vor
der freiheit hätte die nato nicht zu
fürchten bräuchte so einfach so
unterkomplex denn es kommt eben nicht
auf unserer einschätzung der nato an
sondern auf die russische sicht und
erleben die russen seit der deutschen
wiedervereinigung ein unaufhaltsame
vorrücken eine schiene entgegengesetzten
militärbündnisses gegen die russischen
grenzen
meine damen und herren es ist nicht nur
eine auseinandersetzung zwischen
autokratie und demokratie sondern auch
ein zusammen ball politische
militärische und wirtschaftliche
interessen und deshalb ist es auch
falsch diesen konflikt mit schweren
waffen anzuheizen
[Applaus]
so der frühere wenn es militärberater
angela merkels erich fahrt jede
militärische lösung führt in die
katastrophe
wenn deutsche politiker und heute ist es
wieder geschehen postulieren russland
darf nicht gewinnen muss man deshalb
hinzufügen es darf auch nicht verlieren
da eine atommacht auch in einem krieg
nach art des neunzehnten jahrhunderts
die mittel des zwanzigsten und
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts einsetzen
kann wenn sie droht zu unterliegen und
das wollen sie hoffentlich auch nicht im
falle russland kommt ein weiteres
dilemma hin zu
völkerrechtlich normierte ordnungen
haben sich in der geschichte nur dann
als haltbar erwiesen wenn die
unterlegene seite gleichberechtigt
eingebunden war bestes historisches
beispiel ist die wiener ordnung von 1815
nach dem sieg über napoleon in dem
frankreich eine gleichberechtigte rolle
spielen konnte vermieden die akteure von
wien eine dauernde revolutionäre
unzufriedenheit des besiegten das ganze
gegenteil davon war web sei 1919 und
genau das meine damen und herren ist
heute das problem russlands es hat die
einseitigen veränderungen nach 1989
innerlich nie wirklich akzeptiert sie
wären besser im zusammenwirken mit
russland und nicht gegen eine unter
jelzin vorübergehend geschwächte macht
durchgesetzt worden ich vergleiche
hinken immer
die nato osterweiterung war aber mehr
wert sei als wien das hat ein schwaches
russland geschluckt jetzt wo in der
ukraine der kern des zarenreiches wie
der sowjetunion tangiert wird sehen die
russischen eliten eine rote linie
überschritten
solange russland großmacht und atommacht
ist werden abmachungen nur reißfest sein
wenn sie das land innerlich mit trägt
eine westliche ukraine ist es nicht
folglich kann nur ein kompromiss nur ein
kompromiss aber nicht der sieg der einen
oder anderen seite diesen krieg beenden
die lieferung schwerer waffen ist dazu
kein sinnvoller beitrag mehr daran zu
kommen
hessische initiative
deutschlands wäre sehr viel sinnvoller
und wichtiger ich bedanke mich
das wort hat die kollegin maria schafft
zimmermann die fdp
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
ich zitiere der organisierung des
friedens stehen starke kräfte entgegen
sie haben erfahren in welchem bereich
der mensch zurückfallen kann keine
religion keine ideologie keine
glanzvolle entfaltung der kultur
schließt mit sicherheit aus dass aus den
seelischen tiefenschichten der
menschenhass hervorbrechen und völker
ins unheil reißen kann der frieden ist
so wenig wie die freiheit ein urzustand
den wir vorfinden wir müssen ihn machen
im wahrsten sinne des wortes das sagte
willy brandt als er 1971 den
friedensnobelpreis in oslo entgegen
haben heute meine damen und herren
gespenstisch aktuell er sorgte sich
bereits seinerzeit um die zukunft
europas und deutete die verantwortung
deutschlands
51 jahre später werden wir brutal von
diesem szenario eingeholt vor 63 tagen
über vier russland die ukraine morden
und brandschatzen und greift damit auch
aller unserer regeln und werte basierte
ordnung an meine damen und herren eine
ordnung die 1945 als konsequenz aus dem
barbarischen zweiten weltkrieg erwuchs
nie wieder sollte das prinzip des
stärkeren gelten die vereinten nationen
wurden gegründet um künftige
geschlechter vor der geißel des krieges
zu bewahren auf diese charta konnten
sich seit jahrzehnten weltweit alle
staaten berufen nur diese gewissheit ist
seit dem 24
februar zerstört und die erosion
meine damen die auf erosion dieses
werteverfalls nahm vor vielen jahren
seinen anfang die warnzeichen waren da
und die annexion der trimm bereits
brutale realität
das weißbuch wurde erneuert und die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung in den
vordergrund gestellt um dann sagen wir
es ganz deutlich naiv ignorant in
deutscher ruhe dabei zuzusehen wie
russland bereits vor acht jahren ein
krieg in der ost ukraine anzettelte
meine damen und herren
14.000 menschen sind dort seitdem ums
leben gekommen es geht um freiheit und
demokratie um selbstbestimmung um
menschenrechte die mit den füßen
getreten werden und deshalb bittet
deshalb ruft ja deshalb schreibt die
ukraine nach unserer hilfe und das mag
manchen tierisch auf den keks gehen wir
sollten aber solange bereit sein dazu
stehen so lange ist die vollständige
territoriale integrität der ukraine
wieder hergestellt meine damen und
herren
der
vorliegende rang start ist daher unser
codecs wie dir darauf gemeinsam über
parteigrenzen hinweg als
abgeordnete aber vor allem als menschen
reagieren aus der mitte des parlaments
heraus die vergangenen wochen meine
damen und herren waren für uns alle eine
immense herausforderung
wer in deutschland aufgewachsen ist
kennt keinen krieg das ist der
wunderbare teil der geschichte wie man
den krieg begegnet sorgte auch deswegen
für knallharte diskussion und ich bin
sehr froh dass unsere bundesregierung
eingebettet im westlichen bündnis den
hat hat auch schwere waffen an die
ukraine zu liefern und dieses hätte
willy brandt wie folgt eingeordnet er
sagte es 1970 nichts kommt von selbst
und nur wenige ist von dauer darum
besinnt euch auf eure kraft und darauf
dass jede zeit eigene antworten will man
auf ihrer höhe zu sein hat wenn gutes
bewirkt werden soll vielen dank
marie agnes strack zimmermann die
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
und in den letzten wochen ja immer
wieder sich zu wort gemeldet als an der
vehementesten befürworterinnen für die
lieferung schwerer waffen thomas ernte
hören jetzt am rednerpult für die union
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen finde es gut
dass wir uns auch diesen gemeinsamen
antrag geeinigt haben werden sicherlich
manches direkter stringenter formuliert
aber es ist wichtig dass koalition union
hier gemeinsam vorangehen denn eines ist
klar die ukraine braucht die
größtmögliche unterstützung
unseres landes und da ist es wichtig
dass eine mehrheit dem deutschen
parlament ein starkes signal der
verantwortung sendet und sich
entschieden hinter das land stellt das
portal angegriffen wurde
wahr ist aber auch meine damen und
herren das ist ohne die unionsfraktion
heute weder diese debatte noch den
antrag gegeben hätte und dass es
womöglich auch keine bewegung bei der
lieferung schwerer waffen gegeben hätte
es aber möglicherweise weiterhin der
streit in der koalition und ein zaudern
und zögern ganz speziell im kanzleramt
das sind die fakten und das
unterstreicht wie wichtig eine
konstruktive opposition ist meine daher
ein paar worte an die spd gerichtet sie
können natürlich öffentlich und
taktische spielchen vorwürfen gegen weil
sie können hier parteipolitik
kritisieren und trotzdem eine
parteipolitische rede halten oder
ermöglicht vor einer militaristischen
debatte waren nämlich findet es ist ein
völlig absurder und unerträglicher
ausfall gewiesen oder sie können uns wie
er kümmert sich nur antun weiter die
anwesenheit des kanzlers im parlament
fordern kann man alles machen was sie
aber auch tun können und das finde ich
wesentlich sinnvoller wäre es sich
besser mit ihrem kanzler abzustimmen
denn dann würden nämlich nicht morgens
sie öffentlich das gegenteil von dem
erzählen was kanzler und
verteidigungsministerin wenig später
entscheiden und verkünden so wie wir das
bei der freigabe der gepard lieferung
der fall war meine damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der kanzler reist heute zum geburtstag
der deutschen handelskammer nach tokio
kann man machen japan ist natürlich ein
wichtiger partner aber der bundeskanzler
war nicht in kiew er war nicht im
baltikum nicht in tschechien der
slowakei oder in rumänien bei den
nachbarn die zutiefst irritiert und
enttäuscht sind von der zögerlichkeit
dieses bundeskanzlers bei den nachbarn
die ihn von ihren ängsten berichten
könnten vom trauma der russischen
herrschaft über ihre gesellschaften
nachbarn die wirklich alles tun damit
die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnen
dass sie die nächsten sein könnten wenn
putin nicht in der ukraine gestoppt wird
habe ich lege es gibt den wunsch nach
einer zwischenfrage
frisur ort während wichtige signale
gewesen das hätten die reiseziele in
diesen tagen sein müssen meine damen und
herren das hätte ich vom regierungschef
des größten europäischen landes erwartet
hätte denn so einer krise wirklich
führung erwartet wenn wir vorausschauend
führt argumentiert nicht mit punkten die
er kurz darauf immer wieder einkassieren
muss wer umsichtig führt betreibt keine
angst und wer immer als letzter eine
entscheidung trifft meine damen und
herren handelt nicht im verbund mit
partnern sondern muss vom verbündeten
immer erst bedrängt werden bis endlich
etwas passiert
meine damen und herren die zeitenwende
darf nicht nur ein rhetorischer griff
bleiben es braucht jetzt schwere waffen
für die ukraine und die regierung hat
mit diesem antrag die rückendeckung des
parlaments das ist richtig aber für uns
ist damit eine klare erwartungshaltung
verbunden liefern was geht auch die
japaner einst auch die marder
perspektivisch modernere systeme keine
ausreden keine verzögerungen mehr und
die entscheidung für einen gebhard darf
jetzt ruhigstellen des parlaments und
unserer partner sein und ich hoffe
wirklich dass
dieses system auch eingesetzt werden
kann am ende geht es nicht darum dass
wir uns bemüht haben dass wir auch was
geliefert haben es geht einzig und
allein darum dass das ziel erreicht wird
nämlich dass russland militärisch in
ukraine nicht erfolgreich sein darf dort
werden wir sie bessern zum ende durch
kommen zum ende frau präsidentin daran
werden wir sie messen und daran wird
diese bundesregierung auch voller
geschichte gemessen werden deshalb
beherzt handeln statt zaudern der vielen
dank
zum aus erde war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion und jetzt haben wir
ihnen dieser debatte
noch einen redner aber es gibt auch noch
die zeit und die möglichkeit für eine
kurzintervention klaus ernst für die
linke also meine damen und herren wir
diskutieren hier auch der kanzler nach
japan fährt oder nicht von der union
kommen solche diskussionen ich glaube
uns ist gar nicht klar was wir hier
gerade beschließen
und sie diskutieren eine reise eines
kanzlers der kanzler hat vor kurzem
einen wichtigen satz gesagt ja gesagt da
müssen beachten dass möglicherweise das
wort ist bereits zitierte spiegel
interview dass er möglicherweise auf
eine weitere militärische eskalation
auch einen auf einen atomkrieg zu gehen
könnten jetzt hat er bisher schwere
waffen ausgeschlossen und jetzt frage
ich sie alle insbesondere herrn merz
also ich würde sagen ja ich bin ja froh
dass die kanzlerin uns dort beigetragen
hat dass wir uns einige jahre erspart
geblieben sind aber ich habe aber ich
aber ich habe jetzt den eindruck mit dem
was wir hier tun möchte ich sie auch mal
fragen sind eher den nun eine atomare
auseinandersetzung in dieser welt wird
diesen beschluss den wir heute erfassen
näher oder sind wir weiter weg
und ich sage ihnen wir sind mit jedem
schritt den wir hier weiter in richtung
eskalieren dem atomkrieg und der
weiteren auseinandersetzung mehr als
vorher da sind wir als vorher und
deshalb sei und deshalb wundert mich mit
welcher fragen sie sich hier beschäftigt
mit reisen des kanzlers mein gott über
was reden wir denn hier eigentlich die
reden über die frage ob er hier in einem
halben jahr oder im jahr noch durch ein
berlin gehen können das nicht zerstört
ist weil wenn es einen atomkrieg sind
sind ja auch betroffen bei den damen und
herren und ich würde mich freuen wenn
wir hier wenigstens ein wenig darüber
reden könnten welche vorschläge wir
haben den krieg zu beenden außer
zusätzliche militarisierung herr merz
daher von ihnen
unglaublich was wir hier machen
die antwort jetzt kann der kollege
angegeben wenn er möchte bitteschön
vielen dank frau präsidentin ist es ja
auch interessant haben applaus zu sehen
von welchen seiten die zustimmung zu
ihrer einlassung kommt herr kollege
es sind in der tat
wichtige fragestellungen die sie
aufwerfen und deswegen ist ganz klar die
situation so dass wir hier vom
bundeskanzler erwartet hätten dass sie
diese debatte auch anzusprechen und zu
erklären es ist weder die reise
angemessen in diesen tagen wenn diese
fragen auf den tisch legen noch ist es
angemessen die erklärung über das
regierungshandeln über möglicherweise
meinungs- änderungen in einem spiegel
interview kund zu tun sondern hier im
parlament wäre der ort wo der
bundeskanzler das machen hätte sollen
und das ist unsere position und deswegen
haben wir das auch hier richtiger weise
angesprochen dankeschön
für die spd fraktion gebe ich jetzt das
wort dem kollegen dr
und er ist der letzte hier zur
aussprache bevor dann ja auch über die
gemeinsamen antrag abgestimmt werden
soll
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren die
dramatischen opferzahlen des russischen
überfalls auf die ukraine die getöteten
menschen die aushungerung der
zivilbevölkerung mario pohl und an
anderen orten werden wir in diesem haus
niemals hinnehmen und deswegen ist es
richtig dass koalition und cdu csu
opposition in dieser zeit besonnen und
gemeinsam vorgehen dann ist das teil
dann ist es zeit für abwägen des
handelns die menschen stehen hinter der
ruhigen und unaufgeregten politik des
bundeskanzlers die menschen wollen nicht
dass wir kriegspartei werden und ich
sage mal in richtung auf die linken was
wir eben gehört haben wir würden uns
alle sehr viel wohler fühlen uns wäre
besser für dieses land wird die
moralische empörung der linken auch mit
der bereitschaft in hall einherginge
verantwortung zu übernehmen in dieser
zeit und diesem antrag zuzustimmen
meine damen und herren olaf scholz führt
dieses land dazu in die richtige
richtung und er führt es auf die
richtige weise und ich sage dass wir für
das nicht nur wenn er auf diesem stuhl
sitzt sondern er führt das auch wenn er
mit den wichtigsten verbündeten die wir
auf dieser welt haben engen kontakt hält
den die brauchen wir noch in der zukunft
bei damen und herren die linie der
koalition zur waffenlieferung ist
eindeutig wir liefern das was wir
verfügbar haben wir liefern das was wir
entbehren können ohne die sicherheit und
die bündnis zusagen deutschlands zu
gefährden und wir liefern das was der
ukraine in ihrer schwierigen situation
unmittelbar und nachhaltig hilft ihr
selbstverteidigungsrecht wahrzunehmen
was das jeweils konkret bedeutet
definierenden ersten beiden punkten wir
und im letzten punkt natürlich der
ukraine und dabei gibt es keine
vorbehalte beim material darauf haben
wir uns diese woche mit unseren
alliierten in ramstein geeinigt das
signal von rammstein ist eindeutig es
gibt in dieser frage keine alleingänge
sondern wir handeln eng abgestimmt mit
unseren partnern und wir sind in unserer
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht außerordentlich dankbar dass
die mit hohem engagement zu diesem
schulterschluss beigetragen habe
herzlichen dank
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen in dieser
schwierigen situation ist die nato nicht
die bedrohung sondern das große arsenal
der freiheit und der demokratie
aber dieses arsenal der freiheit hat
mehr zu bieten als nur waffenlieferungen
die nato ist eine wertegemeinschaft
deren anziehungskraft weiter zunimmt wie
das interesse von schweden und finnland
an einer mitgliedschaft zeigt die nato
repräsentiert zugleich die größte
wirtschaftliche kraft auf dieser welt
das die die wir gemeinsam mit der eu
einsetzen um russland das hohe risiko
für die eigene zukunft klar zu machen
und die nato ihre mitglieder haben auch
eine kulturelle strahlkraft die
russlands repressiven staatsmodell weit
überlegen ist die freiheit des wortes
dagegen kann russland auf dauer keine
barrieren errichten deswegen ist es
beispielsweise auch richtig dass der
gemeinsame antrag ausdrücklich die
deutsche welle als stimme der freiheit
stärkt und auch darüber hinaus jeder
cent den wir die auswärtige kultur und
bildungspolitik stecken ist auch ein
schritt zur eindämmung von
desinformation von russland und in der
welt
dieses alles zeigt uns
waffenlieferungen werden gebraucht zur
verteidigung der ukraine aber der weg
zur sicherheit und frieden führt eben
auch über andere pfade
deswegen müssen wir uns stets die frage
stellen was unser gemeinsames ziel ist
eins ist klar russland darf diesen krieg
nicht gewinnen aber wie kann er enden da
darf sich die diskussion nicht auf die
vorstellung verengen russland
militärischen der ukraine komplett zu
besiegen und zur kapitulation zu bringen
das ist eine strategie mit hohem risiko
die politische lösung dagegen ist völlig
klar wir brauchen im einklang mit dem
un-generalsekretär und der mehrheit der
weltgemeinschaft einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand
umgehende humanitäre hilfe und einen
friedensschluss
wir brauchen liebe kolleginnen kollegen
eine diplomatische lösung auch wenn sich
bei allen demokratisch gesinnten
mitgliedern dieses hauses der magen
umdreht bei der vorstellung dass die
ukraine mit putin verhandeln muss um
ihre souveränität unabhängigkeit und
territorialen unverletzlichkeit zu
sichern aber es wird am ende nicht
anders gehen und deswegen ist ein großes
und wichtiges signal dass deutschland
bereit ist für diesen fall dauerhaft die
sicherheit der ukraine mit zu
garantieren ich danke ihnen
ich schieße damit die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktion spd cdu/csu bündnis 90/die
grünen und fdp auf drucksache 15 50 mit
dem titel frieden und freiheit in europa
verteidigen umfassende unterstützung für
die ukraine es lägen einige erklärungen
nach § 31 der geschäftsordnung vor die
sie nachher im protokoll wiederfinden
können die fraktion der afg hat
namentliche abstimmung verlangt die
abstimmung erfolgt in der west lobby sie
haben nach zur abgabe ihrer stimme nach
der eröffnung der abstimmung 20 minuten
zeit bitte gehen sie daher nicht alle
gleichzeitig zur abstimmung
ich bitte die schriftführerin und
schriftführer die plätze an den
abstimmungs ohne nein zu nehmen
das ist bereits der fall dafür danke ich
damit eröffne ich die namentliche
abstimmung jetzt
ja und die bundestags vizepräsidentin
katrin göring eckardt hat das noch
einmal erklärt die abstimmung den
amtliche die findet hier wie in den
letzten anderthalb zwei jahren üblich
auf den früheren hier im reichstag statt
in der westlb- ganz genau gesagt das hat
natürlich immer noch den grund dass man
möglichst abstand halten kann und sollte
wäre der abstimmung nicht alle
abgeordneten auf einmal zu den urnen
gehen
deswegen ist die abstimmung auch
eigentlich 20 minuten geöffnet
und dann wird danach ausgezählten das
ergebnis mitgeteilt also dieser
gemeinsame antrag von den
koalitionsfraktionen und der
cdu/csu-fraktion
beinhaltet sozusagen die unterstützung
der bundesregierung für ihren schritt
der diese woche angekündigt worden ist
auch schwere waffen in die ukraine zu
liefern beispielsweise aus industrie
beständen aber vor allem ist darin auch
festgehalten
dass die bundesregierung auch weiterhin
einen sogenannten ringtausch
unterstützt also nato partner wie
beispielsweise slowenien und dass es
jetzt bereits geplant die panzer so wird
ua bauart an die ukraine abgeben deren
bestände sollen dann aufgefüllt werden
mit waffen aus deutschland
dieser antrag den es hier gibt der
insgesamt 40 punkte formuliert mit
forderungen an die bundesregierung der
hat keine bindende wirkung das ist hier
keine gesetzgebung und über
waffenlieferungen beziehungsweise auch
über die möglichkeit zu exporten darüber
entscheidet die bundesregierung
insbesondere der bundessicherheitsrat
aber das soll hier ein starkes signal
sein von den antrag tragenden fraktionen
zumindest mit es in der debatte mehrfach
betont wurde als unterstützung an die
ukraine in ihrem kampf gegen
russland und gegen diesen russischen
angriffskrieg und deswegen gab es auch
eine verständigung erst gestern
nachmittag zwischen den
koalitionsfraktionen und der
unionsfraktion dass man jedoch gemeinsam
diesen antrag macht denn eigentlich
lagen mal zwei unterschiedliche vor
ursprünglich ist dieser
tagesordnungspunkt sowieso nur
aufgesetzt worden weil die cdu csu
fraktion einen weitergehenden antrag ein
weitgehender den antrag hier aufgesetzt
hatte mit der forderung an die
bundesregierung schwere waffen zu
liefern auch beispielsweise
kampfpanzer eventuell sogar aus den
beständen der bundeswehr
der ist wie gesagt zurückgezogen worden
weil man hier dieses gemeinsame signal
setzen wollte auch wenn die debatte
alles andere als harmonisch verlaufen
ist friedrich merz der fraktionschef der
nutzte ja die ukraine debatte durchaus
zu einem generalangriff auf den kanzler
der spd-parteichef lars klingbeil warf
märz der parteipolitische profilierung
vor aber da schwebt im hintergrund
natürlich mit noch sozusagen die
verhandlung über das 100 milliarden euro
paket sondervermögen für die bundeswehr
das derzeit in der parlamentarischen
beratung ist so wir schauen in den
plenarsaal rein denn es geht weiter mit
der nächsten debatte
da geht es um hilfe für unternehmen ein
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigten entspricht julia klöckner
die tote die hinter der internationale
währungsfonds die bundesregierung sie
korrigieren in diesen wochen laufend
ihre wachstumsprognosen nach unten und
die inflationserwartungen nach oben und
unsere wirtschaft kommt ab dem zweiten
quartal in sehr unsicheres fahrer nur
noch zwei prozent wachstum für 22 und
inflationsrate über sechs prozent das
ist eine massive preissteigerung der
höchste wert seit 40 jahren erst corona
und jetzt der russland ukraine krieg
unsere volkswirtschaft bleibt im
krisenmodus die belastungen für
unternehmen und beschäftigte die nehmen
kein ende es geht um belastungen die auf
dauer nicht zu verkraften sind und es
geht um das potenzial für eine echte
wirtschaftskrise und von monat zu monat
werden die wirtschaftszahlen schlechter
da sind abstrakte zahlen verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen aber das sind
ganz konkrete belastungen für betriebe
und beschäftigte vor ort
schauen wir uns die hohen energiekosten
haben die papier- oder glas industrie
hat ihre produktion teilweise
stillgelegt
das dicke ende kommt noch denn über
langfristige lieferverträge sind viele
unternehmen momentan noch gegen hohe
energiekosten abgesichert schauen wir
uns die lieferketten an in der
automobilindustrie laufen die bänder
teilweise oder nur eingeschränkt
wichtige zulieferer teile zulieferer
teile wie kabelbäume die fehlen uns wir
wissen vor shanghai über 300 transporter
stehen dort fest es gibt engpässe es
gibt frachtschiffe die nicht entladen
werden können und unser leben das wird
teurer und das spüren alle ob an der
zapfsäule bei strom und teils rechnungen
oder beim einkauf im supermarkt auch die
preise für getreide sind übrigens
deutlich gestiegen und ich will dass ihr
kurz sagen die bundesregierung
gibt es keine antwort auf die sich
abzeichnende wirtschaftskrise was die
bundesregierung macht ist unterlassene
spiel an dieser stelle auch etwas sagen
zum
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister dass in
dieser zeit wohl lagerhallen für
nahrungsmittel zerstört werden wo anthem
nicht gesichert werden können dass diese
bundesregierung jetzt darauf verzichtet
ökologische vorrangflächen für die
nahrungsmittelproduktion zu nutzen das
ist sträflich das ist vorsatz und das
ist kein handeln aus einem bus um dieser
krise auch entgegen zu gehen was macht
die ampel sie tut so als ginge sie das
alles gar nichts an sie beschließt
übrigens fortlaufend auch
mehrbelastungen vor allen dingen tobt
sie sich aus bei den berichts und
dokumentationspflichten und gerade die
kleineren und mittleren unternehmen die
brauchen mehr luft zum atmen und beim
facharbeitermangel sehen wir das ist
eine wachstumsbremse und genau hier an
dieser stelle wäre die bundesregierung
gefragt eben nicht im stückwerk zu
handeln sondern mit einem guss wir
brauchen jetzt einen impuls für unsere
wirtschaft denn diese krisen müssen
entschieden da angepackt werden eine
entschlossene ausrichtung der
wirtschaftspolitik auf
leistungsfähigkeit auf digitalisierung
auf nachhaltigkeit das ist gefragt und
weil die bundesregierung das nicht tut
haben wir diesen antrag heute vorgelegt
ein gesamtkonzept aus einem guss
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigte das fordern wir von der
bundesregierung sie machen es nicht wir
legen es ihnen vor und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
dürfen die unternehmen die beschäftigte
jetzt eben gerade nicht im regen stehen
lassen wir brauchen ein neues bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz das melde- und
aufbewahrungsfristen verkürzt und
gegebenenfalls auch durch eine
genehmigungsfähige ersetzt und wir
schlagen die einführung von gründer
schutzzonen vor gründe sollen die ersten
zwei jahre weitgehend von bürokratischen
vorschriften befreit werden und für die
krisenzeit da brauchen wir ein belastung
das moratorium und das ist vielleicht
für den einen oder anderen so locker
daher gesagt nur schauen wir uns die eu
ebene an sie macht gerade so weiter
übrigens unterstützt durch die
bundesregierung als gäbe ist diesen
krieg und diese kriege krisen nicht es
geht jetzt darum auch zu überlegen ob
die taxonomie vorstellung von
dokumentationspflichten wirklich das
sind was wir jetzt in dieser krisenzeit
brauchen deshalb brauchen wir jetzt ein
belastungsmoratorium eine bürokratie
bremse und müssen einen schoko
anschalten im übrigen für abschreibung
es ist ja schön dass die bundesregierung
das in ihrem koalitionsvertrag stehen
hat aber worauf warten sie dennoch wenn
nicht jetzt wann dann brauchen wir diese
turbo abschreibung um einen schub für
unsere wirtschaft hier in deutschland zu
bekommen
und genauso sieht es bei der kalten
progression aus worauf warten sie reform
des arbeitszeitgesetzes nicht tägliche
höchstarbeitszeit von den wöchentlichen
höchstarbeitszeit auch in der digitalen
arbeitswelt dass fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetze mir gemacht bringen
sie sich doch jetzt zum blühen wo sind
zb auch ihre umsetzungs offensive bei
der digitalisierung bus der zuständige
minister und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen allein das zeichen dass die als
koalition nicht bereit sind über das
handelsabkommen sitter abzustimmen
morgen dass sie es erneut zum zweiten
mal nicht auf die tagesordnung setzen
lassen mit ihrer mehrheit zeigt dass sie
die zeichen der zeit nicht erkannt haben
wir müssen jetzt handeln jetzt braucht
die wirtschaft einen schub wir haben es
bei der finanz und wirtschaftskrise
gesehen dass es funktionieren kann mit
den richtigen rahmenbedingungen was
machen sie sie haben keinen aktionsplan
sie haben keine konsistente strategie
und wir sagen wir brauchen für made in
germany ein gesamtes dieses
sofortprogramm
deshalb sagen wir auch mehr geld für
verteidigung und unsere freiheit setzt
aber eine funktionierende und blühende
wirtschaft voraus und dafür fordern wir
diese zustimmung zu unserem antrag die
wirtschaftspolitische sprecherin der
unionsfraktion julia klöckner war das
hat hier die debatte eröffnet es geht um
hilfen für unternehmen und beschäftigte
die
unionsfraktion hat dazu einen antrag
vorgelegt er will ein umfassendes
entlastungspaket für die wirtschaft
hören wir mal was die spd sagt ganz
westfalen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
die situation in der wir uns zurzeit
befinden ist sehr ernst die themen neben
mit jeder sitzungswoche an größe zu und
wir brauchen eine kluge
abgewogene intelligente politik die auf
diese situation reagieren und das was
die bundesregierung zurzeit leistet das
sehen wir in den entlastungsprogramm die
nicht einem antrag der opposition
bedürfen sondern die lange schon auf den
weg sind das was die bürgerinnen und
bürgern energiepreisen zurzeit zu
stemmen haben und das was die wirtschaft
an belastungen aushalten hat wird mit
den maßnahmen die die bundesregierung
und die ampel koalition auf den weg
gebracht hat begegnet und das nennen wir
soziale marktwirtschaft meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren
respekt und anerkennung für das was die
bundesregierung in gänze aber vor allen
dingen auch unser wirtschaftsminister
leistet er hat eine menge zu tun unsere
energie versorgungssicherheit zu
organisieren und gleichzeitig den
transformationsprozess in dem unserer
wirtschaftlich befindet zu begleiten und
das ist genau das was wir machen das ist
die sozial ökologische marktwirtschaft
die jetzt genau diese dynamik erfährt
die in den vorgänger regierung nicht zu
sehen war meine damen und herren wir
haben mit dem oster paket was jetzt
vorliegt klar aufgezeichnet wie die
ambitionierten ausbauziele für
erneuerbare energien gestaltet werden
müssen und genau das ist die basis für
industrielle produktion für
wertschöpfung in deutschland und da geht
es dabei natürlich aus kohle und öl und
gas zu reduzieren gerade jetzt mit der
dynamik die versierte seit dem 24
februar haben zu organisieren aber
gleichzeitig auch zu gucken wie kriegen
wir die erneuerbare welt organisiert und
da ist neben dem ausbau natürlich auch
die frage infrastruktur nicht nur lade
infrastruktur sondern auch pipeline
stromnetze hybride netzplanung und genau
das was an speichermöglichkeiten
notwendig ist für einen hochlauf der
wasserstoffwirtschaft genau das sind die
dinge die jetzt zu organisieren sind
dafür brauchen wir auch in einem
europäischen kontext regelungen in die
wir eingebettet sein müssen und deshalb
bedarf es auch nicht nur nationaler
programme sondern auch noch einmal den
dialog mit der europäischen kommission
und mit dem europäischen parlament ob
die dinge die bisher vereinbart worden
sind passen zu dem was jetzt an der
tagesordnung ist und lassen sie mich
noch sagen frau klöckner der antrag der
cdu csu ja es sind einige wichtige
punkte da drin wir haben den antrag
sicherlich als diskussionsgrundlage im
ausschuss da können wir die debatte noch
einmal vertiefen aber ich muss sagen das
was sie hier aufgeschrieben haben
braucht auch ein finanzierungskonzept
und da sind sie blank da kommt überhaupt
nicht und deshalb
und deshalb ist das schon seriöser mit
den hilfsprogrammen die jetzt auf den
weg gebracht worden sind entlastung der
haushalte eine klare fokussierung auf
eine soziale balance in diesem land wir
lassen die menschen nicht allein mit dem
was dort passiert und ein klarer fokus
darauf auch den standort deutschland so
zu organisieren dass es eben mit den
neuen technologien vorwärts geht wenn
man heute mit unternehmerinnen und
unternehmen im dialog ist merkt man doch
die aufbruchstimmung die zuversicht dass
da was passieren muss und ich war
gestern abend bei einer veranstaltung
hier in berlin wo man zeigt an dem
beispiel wilhelmshaven wo sich der
bürgermeister mit dem land niedersachsen
mit bund mit den akteuren und akteuren
vor ort aus der wirtschaft zusammen tut
wo die unternehmen investieren dort den
offshore anbindung erneuerbaren strom
mit wasserstoffwirtschaft zu
organisieren und neben wilhelmshaven
wird das auch brunsbüttel wird das stade
wird das rostock sein genau diese
impulse setzen wir jetzt und das ist die
dynamik die diese ampel koalition nach
vorne bringt und dafür werden wir auch
im wirtschaftsausschuss noch diskutieren
müssen wir haben
wir haben durchaus grund für zuversicht
bislang mangelt nicht an geld glaubt
schon dass die unternehmen genug kapital
haben diese investition zu wuppen mit
staatlichen unterstützung wir werden
noch mal überlegen ob wir dieses geld
was wir jetzt in der kompensation von
hohen energiepreisen nicht auch
bereitstellen müssen für abschreibungen
von jetzt investitionen die getätigt
werden um noch schneller eine
unabhängigkeit von fossilen energien zu
bekommen auch das wird thema sein für
die nächsten wochen und monaten wie
gesagt die
rahmenbedingungen verändern sich sehr
dynamisch und sehr schnell wir
vermitteln zuversicht und organisieren
sicherheit in diesem wandel für diesen
prozess und ich darf sie auffordern die
unterdrückten die regierung in dieser
frage zu unterstützen herzlichen dank an
sagt bernd westphal der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der spd
fraktion und hat doch noch mal darauf
aufmerksam gemacht dass er auch die
bundesregierung vor drei wochen bereits
ein milliardenschweres hilfspaket für
unternehmen in deutschland geschlossen
hat die von den folgen der ukraine
kriegs das ukraine kriegs betroffen sind
enrico kommen denn jetzt für die afg
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
lieben damen und herren kollegen
dieser antrag der union ist ein reiner
schaufensterantrag
niveau union liebe frau klöckner sie
waren ja
regierungsmitglied in der letzten in der
letzten legislatur was hat sie
eigentlich in den 16 jahren der
regierungszeit daran gehindert all das
was jetzt hier in diesen antrag
schreiben damals auch durchzusetzen
weder der krieg noch ihre pandemie sind
für den derzeitigen schlamassel
verantwortlich sondern ihre eigene
politik sie reden jetzt von
bürokratieabbau dabei sind sie es doch
die diesen mount everest bürokratischer
vorschriften aufgetürmt haben sie sind
doch dafür verantwortlich dass der
mittelstand in auflagen und
berichtspflichten versinkt und gegenüber
konzern um ein vielfaches belastet wird
und sie haben doch die rein ideologisch
getriebenen verschärfungen der anti
diskriminierungs und gleichstellungs
gesetzgebung und die änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes zu verantworten
sie haben doch erst die
energieintensiven betriebe durch ihre
monster steuern ins ausland getrieben
und jetzt fordern sie eine verlängerung
der spitzenausgleich übrigens gerade für
kmu ein bürokratisches monster haben sie
sich mal den paragraf 10 des
stromsteuergesetzes
angesehen dass es so ein teil wenn sie
liebe kollegen von der union ernsthaft
am bürokratieabbau interessiert wären
reicht eine einzige forderung nämlich
die rückabwicklung von 16 jahren cdu csu
und merkel politik
meine herren kollegen einiges in ihrem
antrag ist ja gut gemeint vieles ist
aber reines blendwerk
sie wollen jetzt eine entfristung der
home office pauschale wissend dass diese
durch die anrechnung der
werbungskostenpauschale gerade bei
normalen arbeiten den man einfach
verpufft sie von der cdu waren es aber
die unseren antrag im übrigen schon vor
corona mit tatsächlichen und
substanziellen erleichterungen für
mobile arbeit abgelehnt haben sie von
der cdu csu sind es die für den massiven
wohlstandsverlust des mittelstands in
deutschland durch die kalte progression
verantwortlich sind nicht nur dass sie
in den vergangenen jahren dagegen nichts
unternommen haben sie haben die existenz
der kalten progression sogar schlicht
geleugnet und sie sind doch mit ihrer
obskuren energiepolitik dafür
verantwortlich dass kaum ein normaler
arbeitnehmer die schweige denn ein
rentner noch seine strom- oder
heizkostenrechnung bezahlen kann
aber das beste das beste ist du wirklich
dass sie von der union jetzt ernsthaft
die verlängerung der laufzeiten von
kernkraftwerken
verlangen sie haben doch erst die kohle
und kernkraft beerdigt und damit die
energie krise und die abhängigkeiten
verursacht und meine damen und herren
jetzt jetzt tipp wieder aus der
mottenkiste rauszuholen nach diesem
globalisierungs und lieferketten
desaster der letzten jahre darauf muss
man erst mal kommen da dieser antrag
keine der von ihnen zu verantwortenden
ursachen für die krise benennt und
behebt ist der anspruch mit diesem
antrag die bestehenden probleme lösen zu
wollen illusorisch das reicht schlicht
nicht aus deshalb werden wir uns zu
diesem antrag enthalten den öko
sozialistischen unserem antrag der
linken lehnte ab danke sehr
enrico kölling war das für die fdp
fraktion dass die ohne geschlossen
werden sollte noch jemand hier seien der
oder die noch nicht abstimmen konnte
dann wäre es jetzt noch möglich und ich
gebe das wort für bündnis 90 die grünen
den kollegen die talente und die
abstimmungen im hintergrund läuft ja
noch zu dem vorherigen
tagesordnungspunkte wo es um den antrag
ging zur unterstützung der lieferung
schwerer waffen an die ukraine unter
anderem dieter janitschek jetzt hier in
der aussprache wo es um hilfen um
sofortprogramm für unternehmen
beschäftigte geht der
wirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
grünen
die lage der deutschen wirtschaft ist
vergleichsweise
robust angesichts der krisen die wir
gerade global zu erleiden haben der
schreckliche angriffskrieg russlands in
der ukraine
die störung der lieferketten jetzt
aktuell auch wieder in shanghai und
peking übrigens demnächst auch in china
aber natürlich eben auch die folgen der
korona pandemie darüber hinaus die wir
alle noch zu bewältigen haben dafür
stehen wir verhältnismäßig gut da das
ist aber keine garantie für die zukunft
ich hatte heute früh auch ein gespräch
mit unternehmen der logistikbranche die
sehr stark betroffen sind von den
preisschocks auf den energiemärkten
energie zum beispiel hat sich im
verhältnis so diese ja noch mal deutlich
verteuert das heißt auf der einen seite
müssen wir jetzt krisenbewältigung
machen für das was über jahrzehnte und
dafür steht daher sparen ihre
regierungen der vergangenen jahrzehnte
insbesondere nämlich das nichthandeln
bei erneuerbaren energien
energieeffizienz
modernisierung digitalisierung das
müssen wir jetzt in aller schärfe an
schwung nach vorne kommen und sofort und
auf der anderen seite
auf der anderen seite müssen wir
zielgerichtet helfen und das ist der
unterschied von uns zu ihnen sie haben
einen antrag geschrieben wo sie eine
einigkeit haben mit den kollegen von den
linken das ist die maßlosigkeit in der
ausgabenpolitik
wir sind bei der frage der entlastungen
nicht zielgenau
wir wollen unseren haushalt nicht
überlasten wir wollen die nötigen
anpassungen der wirtschaft weg von
russischen öl und gas
befördern wir wollen nicht anreize
schaffen damit wir noch mehr verbrauchen
das im unterschiede die wir
und wir müssen gleichzeitig uns mit
unseren europäischen partnern absprechen
das tun wir bei den hilfsprogrammen
deswegen gibt es das dass temporary
crisis framework das orientiert sich bei
den energieintensiven unternehmen an den
notwendigkeiten die wir haben und es
wird uns trotzdem nicht gelingen all den
wohlstandsverlust im märz hat das ja in
einem bemerkenswerten beitrag
ausgesprochen wir sind möglicherweise in
einer überschreitung unserer wohlstand
stelle angekommen die frage ist nur wie
verteilen wir sozusagen dann auch die
verluste um es mal andersrum zu sagen
das heißt ja nicht dass alle gleich
profitieren oder entsprechen nicht
profitieren und deswegen kommt jetzt
darauf an wirtschaftliche hilfen dort wo
sie notwendig sind auf der einen seite
zeitlich begrenzt zielgerichtet nicht
für alle ich muss nicht den grundpreis
für benzin für suv fahrer garantieren
aber ich muss dafür sorgen dass zum
beispiel menschen die mit gas heizen
durch den winter kommen ich muss dafür
sorgen dass ich überhaupt noch gas habe
durch den winter zu kommen ich muss
dafür sorgen als staatliche institution
dass wir modernisierungsinvestitionen
jetzt anschieben darauf kommt es an das
ist unser ansatz von wirtschaftshilfen
und ihr antrag vor klöckner hat die ein
oder andere
analyse und stellschraube nicht auch
unterschreiben würde beim thema
bürokratieabbau bei der frage der
planungs beschleunigung da wollen wir
vorangehen aber was nicht gegenwärtig
abschließendes dass sie wirtschaftliche
kompetenz dadurch abbilden indem sie
maßlos sind in ihren forderungen und
alles das fordern was in lobbyverbände
einfluss dann aufgabe einer regierung
ist es zu handeln aber zu handeln für
die die es brauchen und das tun wir und
das tun wir kraftvoll vielen dank
zwei anträge liegen diese debatte zu
grunde eine der unionsfraktion und eine
der linksfraktion die drei jahren stieg
hier von den grünen der sie den beiden
anträgen eine gewisse maßlosigkeit in
der ausgabenpolitik über den
unionsantrag haben wir jetzt schon
einiges gehört jetzt werden wir beim
nächsten redner einiges zum
linken-antrag hören die linke fordert
ebenfalls ein hilfsprogramm für
wirtschaft wohlstand und beschäftigung
unter anderem fordert die linke
maßnahmen zur entlastung etwa ein
sondervermögen in höhe von 100
milliarden euro für energiesicherheit
und energie
souveränität
für die linke spricht alexander ulrich
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
janitschek das ist ja wirklich schon
sehr interessant dass ein grüner uns
maßlosigkeit vorwirft weil er 100
milliarden fordern für eine
klimaneutrale wirtschaft und lebensweise
in deutschland währenddessen die grünen
bei 100 milliarden für aufrüstung kein
passender haben also auch die grünen
müssen doch eigentlich sagen
investitionen in klima gerechtigkeit
während sinnvoller wie für ausrüstungen
dass unser vorschlag die antwort auf den
krieg von putin kann doch nicht
aufrüstung bedeutend sondern muss doch
energie souveränität der
energiesicherheit und ausbau dieser
energien bedeuten dass wir da war den
grünen darum kämpfen müssen einen
ähnlichen weg gehen dass sich die grünen
in einem halben jahr eine
regierungsvereinbarung so verändert
hätte ich nie gedacht
wir sind in einer wirtschaftlich
schwierigen lage der
bundeswirtschaftsminister musste gestern
die wachstumsprognosen korrigieren wir
glauben dass auch diese zahlen noch sehr
optimistisch sind die jetzt dargestellt
werden denn viele sachen sind noch nicht
eingepreist und deshalb sind auch die
hilfen die bisher von der
bundesregierung beschlossen worden sind
sowohl für die wirtschaft soforthilfen
als auch die programme und ambitioniert
und viel zu klein und ob sie die
sozialverbände und auch die
gewerkschaften sind oder 4 anderen
interessengruppen ich sagen hier muss
nachgebessert werden und herr westphal
denn sie sagen dass das wäre soziale
marktwirtschaft erklären sie mal einen
rentner oder einer rentnerin warum sie
300 euro nicht bekommen das hat mit
sozialer marktwirtschaft nichts zu tun
eine große gruppe die schwere last wird
ihnen als an den rand gestellt da müssen
sie im gesetzgebungsverfahren noch mal
nachbessern
wir haben deutlich gemacht dass wir
druck machen müssen bei dem umbau der
wirtschaft auf wasserstoff auf
erneuerbare energien dass wir da viel
mehr geld in die hand nehmen müssen und
dann kommt ja immer die fdp die sagt das
ist nicht zu machen wir müssen wir das
schnell zurück zur schuldenbremse und
zur schwarzen null wir hoffen dass auch
diese krise mal erkennt aber dass wir
durch diese krise erkennt dass die
schuldenbremse und die schwarze null
keine zukunft haben kann wir brauchen
dringend
zukunftsinvestitionen damit deutschland
nicht abgehängt wird und dieser krieg
und die wunder pandemie haben gezeigt
wir müssen deutlich mehr investieren
nicht nur in deutschland sondern auch in
europa deshalb muss auch der stabilitäts
und wachstumspakt in europa reformiert
werden die goldene regel nach
investitionen nicht mitgerechnet bei der
verschuldung muss endlich eingeführt
werden
[Applaus]
aber und das ist bei einer sozialen
marktwirtschaft r&b-star müsste das auch
eine antwort sein dass bedarf auch mal
die frage stellen jetzt zahlt sind
eigentlich auch die kosten die der staat
aufwenden muss und wir hören nichts
davon von dieser bundesregierung das
auch mal die krisen und kriegsgewinnler
mal beteiligt werden an diesen kosten es
gibt sehr viele unternehmen die sich die
hände reiben auch nach dem heutigen
beschluss schwere waffen liefern warum
gehen wir noch mal hin besteuert mal
diesen krisen und kriegsgewinnler damit
endlich auch mal die mit dazu beitragen
dass der staat seine aufgaben erfüllen
kann deshalb
andy vermögensabgaben an ran an die
extraprofite der wirtschaft
und wir haben die debatte ja schon sehr
aufgeführt in herne tschechische stehe
nicht wir haben gemeinsam noch zu
oppositionszeiten
auch das programm der gewerkschaften mit
dem industrieverbänden verteidigt wir
brauchen vielmehr zukunftsinvestition
das ist die sachen die zahlen genannt
worden von mindestens 500 milliarden den
nächsten zehn jahren warum stellen sie
sich jetzt sagen das wäre maßlos als vor
einem halben jahr die richtige
entscheidung war sie können nicht nur
weil es jetzt vier minister haben ihre
politik komplett verändern es muss viel
mehr getan werden diesem land um
arbeitsplätze zu sichern um wohlstand zu
generieren um dem klimawandel zu
begegnen und da ist unser programm an
sondervermögen notfalls zu 100
milliarden eine richtige antwort an eine
andere antwort wie nur der
waffenindustrie zu helfen denn diese
zukunftsinvestition zum die falschen und
ganz zum schluss
wir glauben auch dass die
wirtschaftlichen schockwellen in diesem
jahr noch groß sein werden deshalb ist
schon jetzt richtig und wichtig dass auf
70 signal setzen dass kurzarbeit die
richtige antwort sein kann deshalb muss
die kurzarbeit ausgedehnt werden bis
mindestens ende des jahres vielen dank
auch weiter
der kollege reinhard houben hat das wort
für die fdp-fraktion
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
am 13 04 voeckler haben sie gegenüber
dpa das vorliegende sofortprogramm für
unternehmen und beschäftigte
platziert vorgelegt haben sie den antrag
aber erst knapp zwei wochen später
nämlich gestern bei einem sofortprogramm
sollte man doch eigentlich erwarten dass
es auch sofort vorgelegt wird aber spaß
beiseite
als ich in den antrag gelesen habe was
da so alles drinsteht habe ich mir die
frage gestellt
verfolgt die cdu/csu eigentlich die
arbeit der bundesregierung
hat den seit der pressemitteilung anfang
april niemand mehr diesen antrag
gegengelesen
geschaut ob bestimmte maßnahmen die
gefordert werden nicht schon längst
erledigt sind und
ich werde darauf kommen
anders kann ich es mir ehrlich gesagt
nicht erklären dass sie eine temporäre
unterstützung für besonders von der
krise betroffenen unternehmen fordern
sie forderten durch schafften garantien
und kredite darlehen und ein kfw
programm und wenn sie am 13 04 dieses
papier ankündigen aber am achten vierten
die minister lindner und habe
entsprechend schon mit maßnahmen in die
öffentlichkeit geht muss ich schon die
frage stellen wer hat denn ihr papier
geschrieben und hat das nicht
kontrolliert
und außerdem meine damen und herren die
überbrückungshilfe 4 steht doch
weiterhin zur verfügung auch darauf
nehmen sie keinen bezug in ihrem papier
weiter hinten im papier steht dann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die zukunft einer gasversorgung die
nicht von gasimporten aus russland
abhängig ist und unsere souveränität
gewährleistet ja meine damen und herren
was macht denn die bundesregierung wo
war denn bitteschön minister habe der
war doch in katar hat sich darum
gekümmert
lng ports werden jetzt gebaut also sie
müssen ihre papiere schon irgendwie an
die politische wirklichkeit anpassen
sonst sind sie eben nicht glaubwürdig
und
dann sprechen sie das thema
digitalisierung an dadurch besonders
viel freude
darf ich zu ende ausführen frau kollegin
glöckner
es ist in den letzten jahren viel
besprochen wurden über
diversifizierung und es ist viel über
digitalisierung gesprochen worden und
wenn sie mal ihr forderungskatalog ihres
antrages angucke dann
sehen sie alle forderungen von punkt a
bis punkte sind im koalitionsvertrag
gesetzt und dann frage ich mich dass sie
nach vier monaten erwarten bei einem
thema was uns seit einem jahrzehnt
beschäftigt dass sie dann sofortige
ergebnisse erwarten ist politisch an der
stelle einfach ebenfalls unseriös
die bundesregierung und besonders
minister wichtig ist bei diesem thema
unterwegs und wir werden ergebnisse in
dieser ampel sicherlich vorlegen können
aber wie gesagt nicht zwingend nach vier
monaten das halte ich auch nach ihren
regierungs ergebnissen der letzten 16
jahren auch ein bisschen schwierig
ausgerichtet jetzt zu sagen jetzt muss
alles ganz schnell also zusammengenommen
bitte setzen sie sich doch mit der
politischen situation
auseinander prüfen sie was die regierung
macht und was sie nicht macht und kommen
dann mit einem etwas schmaleren papier
wo dann vielleicht wirklich vernünftige
kritikpunkte sind wieder auf uns zu dann
können wir gerne darüber diskutieren
seriöse oppositionsarbeit sieht
jedenfalls nicht so aus wie ein
sammelsurium von schönen forderungen die
man scheinbar aus den
unterschiedlichsten quellen
abgeschrieben hat und eine bemerkung zur
linken
das ist mehr so nüssel 2.0 was sie hier
vorgelegt haben das einzige was mir noch
gefehlt hat in ihrem antrag dass dann
auch das tempolimit eingebracht hätten
das haben sie nun leider nicht getan
deswegen können wir auch ihrem antrag
nicht zum stift vielen dank
die arena gegen wales und bären seiner
rede gab es einen wechsel im
bundestagspräsidium die sitzungsleitung
hat jetzt wolfgang kubicki der
bundestags- vizepräsident
der namentlichen abstimmung begann geben
auf das ja alle warten über den antrag
der fraktionen spd cdu csu bündnis
90/die grünen und fdp
frieden und freiheit in europa
verteidigen umfassende unterstützung für
die ukraine druckserver 20
1550 habt ihr gegen die stimmkarten 693
mit ja haben gestimmt
586 mit nein haben gestimmt 100
enthaltungen 7 der antrag ist damit
angenommen und wolfgang kubicki hat
sozusagen mitgebracht das ergebnis zu
der abstimmung über den gemeinsamen
antrag der ampel fraktionen zusammen mit
der größten opposition der
cdu/csu-fraktion da ging es ja unter
anderem unterstützung für die ukraine um
ein signal zu senden und auch um die
weitere lieferung von schweren waffen
dieser antrag hat keine bindende wirkung
er ist sozusagen unterstützung für die
bundesregierung und soll vor allem ein
signal richtung ukraine senden und ist
hier ja mit sehr großer mehrheit
angenommen und dem zugestimmt worden so
jetzt geht es aber weiter hier in der
aussprache und wo ist ja geht um hilfe
für unternehmen es spricht jetzt
sebastian bremen für die unionsfraktion
zielgerichtet und gut geholfen durch die
korona hilfen durch das kurzarbeitergeld
und die kurzarbeitergeldregelung durch
kfw kredite und anderes so dass wir
eigentlich gemeinsam im betrieblichen
bereich gut aus der krise herauskomme
nun kommen aber neue belastungen der
zulieferengpässe fachkräftemangel stark
gestiegene preise und natürlich der
ukraine konflikt und alle ihre
bisherigen maßnahmen liebe kollegen und
kollegen von der ampel zielen eigentlich
nur auf den privaten bereich im
unternehmerischen bereich erhoben ich
weiß nicht was sie da vor ihnen
angekündigt haben ich weiß nicht was in
diesem bereich sie gemacht hätten um die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der deutschen
wirtschaft jetzt anzukurbeln und
investitionen voranzutreiben
sie machen in diesen bereich der zeit
nichts liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und ich möchte mal zwei punkte
zwei punkte herausgreifen
aus unserem sehr umfangreichen antrag
die sich sofort umsetzen könnten und die
natürlich auch geeint werden das eine
ist
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten
finanzminister lindner im wahlkampf und
auch jetzt immer die turbo
abschreibungen 100% sofortabschreibung
übrigens sofortabschreibung heißt sie
müssen es auch sofort durchsetzen
vielleicht sie haben sie angekündigt es
ist nichts vorgelegt das würde
investitionen ankurbeln und würde
übrigens liquidität schaffen und würde
auch sich selber finanzieren weil es
eine verschiebung effekte sind lieber
kollege herr brandt sie haben das ja
selber beantragt auch in der letzten
periode übrigens die grünen auch der
bundesfinanzminister sagt er will es
machen wahrscheinlich will die spd nicht
setzen sie es durch und setzten sie
diese turbo abschreibung endlich um
liebe kolleginnen kollegen
und ein zweiter bereich der steuerliche
verlustvortrag und der steuerliche
verlustvortrag auch hier gibt es aus der
letzten periode übrigens ist es
gescheitert damals an der spd gibt es
umfangreiche anträge von grünen und von
gelb und von uns den steuerlichen
verlust rückt zu verlängern über drei
jahre also über die krisenjahre hinaus
bis zu 2000 19 und den verlustvortrag
nicht einzuschränken wir jetzt
eingeschränkt wird auch das wäre eine
maßnahme die wir gemeinsam durchsetzen
könnten die grünen haben es gefordert
die fdp hat gefordert die cdu/csu als
gefordert der bundesfinanzministers
gefordert wahrscheinlich scheitert an
der spd aber es könnten wir gemeinsam
durchsetzen auch das ist finanzierbar
weil es eine reine verschiebung ist von
steuersubstrat von einem jahr in das
andere sofort machbar können sie tun sie
sind jetzt in der regierung die anträge
die sie damals gestellt haben
interessieren sie anscheinend nicht mehr
und liebe kolleginnen kollegen genau das
wäre die maßgabe jetzt schnell helfen
indem man liquidität schafft den
unternehmen durch abschreibungen durch
verlustverrechnung aus eigener kraft
liquidität schaffen der unternehmen aus
eigener kraft und liquidität schafft
wachstum denn wir brauchen jetzt
wachstumsimpulse für den deutschen
mittelstand und für die deutsche
wirtschaft liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und wenn sie es nicht tun und wenn sie
es nicht tun legen sie die axt an die
deutsche wirtschaft an und an den
wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres
mittelstandes deswegen kann ich sie nur
auffordern nehmen sie die anträge die
sich selber gestellt haben in der
letzten periode ernst und setzen sie es
jetzt um sie haben jetzt die möglichkeit
nicht nur reden sondern wirklich jetzt
auch handeln handeln ist jetzt das gebot
der stunde ihre kollegin kollegen wir
sind gerne bereit in den beratungen
miteinander zu sprechen und uns hier
auszutauschen damit wir diese punkte
wenigstens gemeinsam umsetzen können
herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege bremen
[Applaus]
nächsten der kollege sebastian roloff
spd fraktion
vielen dank herr präsident meine damen
und herren ich habe wir haben ja heute
schon viel über konstruktive
oppositionsarbeit gehört und gesprochen
und ich habe eine halbe stunde zugehört
und hat manchmal mehrmals auf die
tagesordnung geguckt ich habe
verzweifelt das sofortprogramm über das
wir reden gesucht ich hab es nicht
gefunden es liegt zumindest nicht vor
kann liegen aber bei klöckner es sieht
eher so aus als hätte da jemand eine
festplatte aufgeräumt und alles was man
irgendwo noch gefunden hätte
zusammenkopiert im haus geschickt aber
es ist kein sofortprogramm weil ich
erkläre ihnen auch gerne gleich warum es
ist nämlich mit lichten groß dass alles
um forderung style falsch ist die
einleitung ist korrekt wir stehen vor
riesigen herausforderungen
transformation nach chur wird jetzt
natürlich auch die frage ukraine und die
entsprechenden folgen die analyse ist
richtig und sie teilweise auch wichtige
beschlüsse oder forderungen auf der
einen seite sind fordern zum beispiel
dass wir ein besonderes paar
maßnahmenpaket für besonders von der
krise betroffene unternehmen machen oder
für energieintensive unternehmen
von ihm ist das haben wir schon gemacht
weiß nichts können sie natürlich fordern
es ist schon lange auf den weg gebracht
genauso beim thema bürokratie sie
fordern ein neues bürokratie
entlastungsgesetz finde ich ganz
bezaubernd sind wir dafür sind wir in
der erstellung ist schon auf dem weg
genauso wie das unternehmensbasis
register und natürlich die
beschleunigung von planungs und
genehmigungsprozesse da sind wir total
mit ihnen auf einer linie das problem
ist nur es hätte dieses antrags nicht
bedurft sondern es ist schon auf dem weg
beim bürokratieabbau ist aus unserer
sicht aber klar dass das natürlich ein
selbstzweck ist auf der einen seite auf
der anderen seite ist aber natürlich
nicht dazu führen darf dass soziale und
ökologische standards abgebaut werden
dementsprechend werden wir da sehr genau
hinschauen im ziel sind er aber vereint
dann und das finde ich noch viel
charmanter fordern sie sagt die sie
selber jahrelang verhindert haben
verbesserung der fachkräfte an werbung
zum beispiel wollen die unternehmen
schon immer wollte auch die spd
nachweislich in der letzten regierung
immer haben sie immer verhindert finden
sie auf einmal toll finden wir gut dass
es da einen lernprozess gab es aber auch
fraglich ob das mit einem mit einem
sofortprogramm einhergeht themen die
frauenerwerbsquote oder so diskutieren
sie gar nicht das finde ich auch immer
einigermaßen verstörend und bei der
frage beschleunigung beim aufbau von
digitaler infrastruktur muss man nur die
namen dobrindt und scheuer sagen und
dann festhalten wer da ganz
offensichtlich gebremst hat und dass das
ganz offensichtlich nicht an uns lag in
der letzten regierung
und es wird aber leider noch schlimmer
deswegen sie ahnen dass wir ihrem
sofortprogramm hier im angeblichen
wahrscheinlich nicht zustimmen werden
ich fordere auch unverantwortliche dinge
und da habe ich ihnen sehr genau
zugehört vor klöckner die sich über das
belastungs moratorium gesprochen haben
es wundert mich ein bisschen der kollege
altmaier hat da vor kurzem relativ breit
schiffbruch erlitten dementsprechend
habe ich noch nicht so ganz verstanden
warum sie daraus nichts gelernt haben
und da nicht einen schritt weiter sind
war völlig klar ist dass die die die
fortschritte die man blick auf
lieferketten und nachhaltigkeit erreicht
hat nicht einfach durch ein
belastungsmoratorium einerseits wieder
einkassieren kann es auch gar nicht
wirkt also reden sie da mal gerne mit
kollegen altmaier dann sehen sie dass
das nicht funktioniert und herr kollege
bringen wir sind ja beide aus bayern
wenn sie in diesem sofortprogramm auch
den weiterbetrieb von kernkraftwerken
fordern kann ich können wir gerne mal
auf unseren ministerpräsidenten zu gehen
der untergrund näher bei ihnen in
nürnberg als bei mir der uns ja immer
erklärt atomkraft ist super aber
endlager in bayern geht gar nicht
erneuerbare energien sind prinzipiell
schon ganz okay aber abstand brauchen
wir 10h regelung und eigentlich wollen
wir dann wieder so schwer wie möglich
machen also da ist viel kokolores dabei
so deutlich muss ich sagen und wer zur
frage ob atomkraftwerke jetzt in der
situation noch weiter laufen sollten mir
nicht glaubt oder der regierung nicht
glaubt kann sich ja immerhin auf die
entsprechenden fachgutachten verlassen
da sind sie leider auf einem irrweg und
es wäre schön wenn sie von dem wieder
runterkommen
schließlich
sind da aber auch wieder beieinander
wenn wir darüber sprechen dass wir ein
milliardenprogramm für
steuererleichterungen brauchen auch
steuersenkungen gegebenenfalls für eine
gesunde wirtschaft klar ist aber auch
dass wir dann ein riesenproblem
bundeshaushalt haben und da könnte man
sich jetzt natürlich auch mal drüber
unterhalten auch die schuldenbremse so
eine gute idee war da sind wir uns in
der regierung auch noch nicht ganz einig
aber wir haben uns immerhin auf eine
aussetzung verständigt klar ist aber
auch dass dieser investitionsbedarf
irgendwo herkommen muss und dazu sagen
sie auch nichts außer dass sie wohlfeile
forderungen stellen ich darf zum
abschluss alle kolleginnen und kollegen
der union die einer konstruktiven
mitarbeit interessiert sind herzlich
einladen diese mit uns im
wirtschaftsausschuss zu führen das
funktioniert ja teilweise auch ganz gut
es ist in der öffentlichkeit im moment
ein bisschen er trump würde ich das so
sagen darf aber vielleicht kommen sie
von dem trip wieder runter herr merz hat
geradezu aber wir würden sie auch nicht
verraten wenn sie sich in den fragen
dann an uns wenden und konstruktiv mit
uns über themen reden das heute hilft
leider nicht weiter vielen dank
[Applaus]
als nächster redner das wort der kollege
dr malte kaufmann
erster obmann im wirtschaftsausschuss
für die afg
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
nach 16 jahren regierung merkel mit
teils verheerenden auswirkungen auf den
standort deutschland
fordert die union nun ein sofortprogramm
für die wirtschaft besser spät als nie
könnte man sagen
ihr antrag liebe kollegen von der union
ist ein rundumschlag um vieles anzugehen
was jahrelang von ihnen versäumt wurde
beispielsweise wollen sie endlich die
öffentliche verwaltung digitalisieren
und modernisieren das wollen wir als ard
auch und zwar schon lange
auch viele anderen andere ihrer
vorschläge wirken wie bei uns
abgeschrieben beispielsweise der
überfällige bürokratieabbau viele ihrer
forderungen sind aus unserer sicht also
wichtig und dennoch ihr ganzer antrag
macht den eindruck als wollten sie nur
an ein paar einzelnen stellschrauben
drehen um die wirklich großen probleme
unserer zeit dagegen machen sie einen
weiten bogen
so rufen sie jetzt beispielsweise nach
einer ich zitiere sicheren bezahlbaren
und souveränen energieversorgung das ist
richtig aber der entscheidende zweite
satz fehlt er müsste lauten eine
energieversorgung also wie wir sie
früher hatten bevor eine unionsgeführte
bundesregierung in einer nacht und
nebelaktion die sichere und
grundlastfähige kernkraft abgeschafft
hat und dann auch noch den ausstieg aus
der kohleverstromung beschlossen hat um
beides gegen unzuverlässigen flattr
strom aus wind und sonne einzutauschen
das wären mut zur wahrheit liebe
kollegen
immerhin schlagen sie vor man solle den
weiterbetrieb von kernkraftwerken prüfen
ich frage sie was gibt es denn da jetzt
noch zu prüfen angesichts der aktuellen
dramatischen versorgungslage
unter immer näher rückenden energiekrise
natürlich müssen die meiler am netz
bleiben was denn sonst
weiterhin fordern sie die verminderung
der energiepreise durch
steuerentlastungen
was sie dagegen nicht sagen ihre co2
steuer ist es doch die die preise an den
tankstellen ganz bewusst und permanent
nach oben treiben soll diese steuer muss
weg ersatzlos
das aber meine damen und herren das aber
fordern sie nicht warum damit würden sie
ja zugeben dass die links grüne politik
der ära merkel ein großer fehler war in
ihrem antrag stehen viele gute sachen
und bestritten aber das große ganze
fehlt die fatalen fehler der letzten
jahre werden nicht benannt und nicht
korrigiert deshalb werden wir uns
enthalten vielen herzlichen dank
sagen meinte kaufmann für die fw
fraktion
und katharina becker erwarten wir jetzt
hier am rednerpult die finanzpolitische
sprecherin der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe fraktionen auch der
cdu/csu ich möchte mich als erstes noch
einmal bedanken dass wir heute gemeinsam
verantwortung übernommen haben als
deutschland gegenüber der ukraine
vielen dank
und es geht jetzt darum wie wir im
rahmen dieser krisen aber auch anderer
krisen helfen unserem land unseren
beschäftigten unseren unternehmen
unserer wirtschaft die deutsche
bundesregierung macht mit dem
entlastungspaket 12 steuerquote steuer
hilfe gesetz mit
wirtschaftshilfen in unfassbarer
größenordnung in bezug auf kredite aber
auch mit zuschüssen ein riesiges angebot
ein riesiges paket und parallel geben
wir noch
zukunftsorientierung denn die zukunft
dieses kontinents und dieses landes ist
energie unabhängig und mit
siebenmeilenstiefeln schön dass sie da
sind kein minister gehen wir hier voran
in die energieunabhängigkeit und eine
prosperierende grüne zukunft darauf
freuen wir uns das ist der fortschritt
dieser ampel
bei dem master diese vorlägen ein
sammelsurium wurde ja schon geschrieben
musste ich direkt bei der ersten erst
mal schmunzeln wir haben ja gerade die
degressive abschreibung beschlossen ein
großes paket mit zehn milliarden
belastung über die nächsten vier jahre
entlastung für die unternehmen belastung
für den haushalt wir haben uns geeinigt
auf eine super abschreibung und sie
schlagen jetzt noch eine turbo
abschreibung vor wobei sie selber auch
bei der degressiven afa völlig dabei
waren das ist ein lustiges wort spiel
aber kein wesentlicher beitrag zur
debatte bei der umsatzsteuer erfordern
sie diverse entlastungen und behaupten
das würde dass verbraucher klima
unterstützen dabei wissen wir alle
umsatz steuersenkungen haben nicht
unbedingt diesen effekt die preise
werden sie unbedingt weiter gegeben das
ist nicht zielgerichtet das sind nochmal
kosten energie steuersenkung strom
steuersenkung all das kostet und hat
noch nicht mal mehr die lenkungswirkung
die wir uns wünschen denn das sind
mengen anreize und wir müssen doch
gerade wollte er eben anders
wirtschaften und nicht mehr einfach nur
an energie verbrauchen und das sind
einfach die falschen dinge ihre
maßnahmen führen leider zu weiterer
marktverzerrung auch zwischen groß und
klein setzen die falschen anreize und
haben nicht kalkulierbare kosten das
geht gegen solide finanzen was sie
selber eigentlich fordern
und erschütternd an ihre analyse finde
ich
dass das thema klima gar nicht vorkommt
sie waren bestimmt auch schon mal in
davos und die top-3 risiken der
weltwirtschaft jedem januar publiziert
wurden mit klima wandelt lieferengpässen
dadurch wegen schlimm wetterereignissen
zu tun und sie geben doch immer vor so
nah an der wirtschaft zu sein das sind
die dinge die da auch extrem bewegen und
deswegen kann man gerade jetzt nichts es
so verkaufen als wäre es ein belastungs
moratorium sondern es ist eine
entlastung für unternehmen wenn wirklich
klarheit an den kapitalmärkten haben mit
sustainable finanzmaßnahmen wohin das
geld fließen soll denn wir brauchen die
privaten investitionen und so kann auch
wieder prosperität entstehen und ich
bitte sie kommen sie bitte an mit uns im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert die
zukunft ist beschrieben der fortschritt
den wir wollen und wir arbeiten da gerne
konstruktiv miteinander aber nicht mit
nicht wirksam sammelsurium an maßnahmen
die einfach nicht die richtigen effekte
haben vielen dank
an frau kollegin wird
[Applaus]
als nächster redner das wort der kollege
markus herbrand fdp fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen liebe kollegen
der cdu
also um einen innovationspreis sollten
sie sich mit diesem antrag wirklich
nicht bewerben alles aber auch wirklich
alles was ihr nieder geschrieben steht
gibt oder gab es in irgendeiner form
schon der antrag ist ein sammelsurium an
plagiaten die sie von allen seiten
regelrecht schamlos kopiert haben
ich habe auch fdp forderungen darin
gefunden das gebe ich zu auf der suche
nach neuem bin ich dann auch fündig
geworden wie die kollegin gesagt hat die
turbo abschreibung aber auch nur auf den
ersten blick denn auf den zweiten blick
muss mehr sagen selbst das haben wir in
teilen schon wenn wir nur an die
digitalen wirtschaftsgüter denken die
wir im augenblick er auch schon mit
einer nutzungsdauer unterstellte
nutzungsdauer von einem jahr sehr
schnell abschreiben so schnell wie es
eigentlich nur geht
aber wir sehen hier eben auch klar und
deutlich was wir als ampel anders
vorhaben wir wollen gezielt und
eben nicht mit der gießkanne sondern
eher mit der spritze die identifizierten
probleme fördern die digitalisierung und
die dekarbonisierung bekämpfen das sind
probleme die sie uns ja auch
hinterlassen haben und wir haben uns im
koalitionsvertrag darauf verständigt
dass gezielt anzugehen und eben diese
super afa auf
den weg zu bringen entschuldigung auf
den weg zu bringen und herr kollege
leben oder auch ich glaube frau klöckner
hat es auch gesagt warum kommt sie nicht
warum kommt sie nicht sämtliche
spitzenverbände der deutschen wirtschaft
haben gesagt dass das im augenblick
eigentlich gar nicht die richtige zeit
dafür sein wie sie diese super art
vereinen anschrift zu man muss einfach
auch mal festhalten dass nicht jede
maßnahme immer zu jedem zeitpunkt
richtig ist und wir werden das machen
und übrigens wirkt die ampel auch schon
an anderer stelle für april schritt für
schritt verfolgen wir unsere ziele und
zeigen auch die notwendige flexibilität
dabei wenn das wirklich notwendig ist
weil die super fan noch nicht kommt
verlängern wir jetzt gerade die
degressive afa auch das ist eine sehr
gute und wichtige regelung um weitere
investitionen anzuheizen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
es hier nicht nur mit einem plagiat zu
tun es ist auch noch eine märchen liste
märchen nicht deshalb weil die
vorschläge nicht in teilen sehr sinnvoll
lernen sondern weil für deren umsetzung
die sterne als silbertaler nur so vom
himmel fallen müssten möglicherweise
besser sogar als gold
insofern fehlt es sowohl der langen
liste als auch der union an zwei
aspekten es mangelt zum einen an der
staatlichen an staatlichen
verantwortungsbewusstsein die lage wegen
der und lukrative krise wegen corona
wegen der inflationären wirkungen ist in
der tat sehr ernst mit solchen kopierten
antrag anträgen zeigen sie dass sie die
situation nicht angemessen ernst nehmen
und zum anderen wenn man forderungen in
milliardenhöhe aufstellt dann muss man
auch sagen woher die mittel kommen
sollen wie paradox dass sie sich
gleichzeitig als seriöse haushälter
profitieren möchten und auf der anderen
seite viele milliarden ausgaben fordern
und nicht ansatzweise sagen wo das geld
herkommen soll
und schließlich gar nicht ihnen auch
nicht ersparen den ein oder anderen
vorschlag haben sie selber ja hier schon
seit jahren formuliert sie bleiben uns
schuldig weshalb sie in den letzten 16
jahren diese forderung selbst nie
umgesetzt haben es kommen ja noch redner
der union vielleicht könnte man das mal
aufklären um der versachlichung hier
genüge zu tun liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ein solcher antrag wird der
aktuellen krisensituation nicht gerecht
und deshalb ist es auch gut dass wir
heute direkt darüber abstimmen und keine
ausschussberatung mehr dafür verwenden
herzlichen dank
vielen dank herr kollege herein
[Applaus]
nun hat das wort der kollege hansjörg
durz cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren
wenn millionen von menschen eine
politische gemeinschaft bilden dann
braucht es ein narrativ eine erzählung
die aus ganz vielen ich sein wir machen
und dabei spielt in deutschland das
wohlstands versprechen eine zentrale
rolle vom wirtschaftswunder bis zum
exportweltmeister wirtschaftlicher
erfolg ist ein kernelement und zur dna
mit den worten eines amerikanischen
polit strategen könnte man
zusammenfassen
economy stupid
und das muss man diese bundesregierung
tatsächlich auch noch mal deutlich sagen
eine regierung die ein entlastungspaket
beschließt ohne jegliche entlastung für
unternehmen das kann nicht sein
die wirtschaftsmacht deutschland gerät
zunehmend unter druck nach zwei jahren
und der hoffnung auf mehr normalität und
wirtschaftliche erholung belasten der
angriffskrieg russlands gestörte
lieferketten und die inflation die
bilanz so dass sämtliche
wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute und auch
die bundesregierung ihre
wirtschaftsprognosen spürbar senken
mussten
kurzfristige hilfsmaßnahmen für
unternehmen sind absolut richtig und
wichtigste sind die notversorgung akuter
beschwerden was wir aber auch dringend
brauchen ist ein langfristiges
fitnessprogramm und deswegen muss unser
wirtschaftsminister nicht nur
notfallsanitäter sein sondern auch
fitnesstrainer
während unter der krone krise vor allem
der dienstleistungssektor litt stellen
die aktuellen herausforderungen
die deutsche industrie vor große
probleme und damit einen der wohlstands
garanten unseres landes für diesen es
bezahlbare energie elementar wir alle
wissen aber dass die energiekosten in
den nächsten jahren tendenziell eher
weiter steigen werden und umso wichtiger
ist es dass wir unsere
wettbewerbsfähigkeit insgesamt deutlich
verbessern so schnell wie möglich meine
damen und herren unser ziel muss sein
dass wir in deutschland die besten
rahmenbedingungen für gründer und
unternehmer haben
das fitnessprogramm für die wirtschaft
dass wir mit diesem antrag vorlegen
beinhaltet eben nicht nur forderungen
die geld kosten wie vorher mehrfach
angeklungen ist sondern vor allem auch
maßnahmen die die rahmenbedingungen
verbessern um unternehmen das bestehen
im wettbewerb zu ermöglichen
und wachstum generieren drei elemente
möchte ich herausgreifen erstens die
bundesregierung der auf die wirtschaft
nicht weiter mit paragraphen und
vorschriften gängeln übrigens auch nicht
durch aktuelle gesetzgebung da besteht
nämlich auch große gefahr darin
unternehmen brauchen luft zum atmen wir
verschreiben der wirtschaft eine
bürokratie diät und ganz kurzfristig die
unternehmen brauchen ein
belastungsmoratorium
zweitens
der staat muss schneller agiler und
digitaler werden
endlos lange planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren bei müssen dynamik
und innovation das sehen wir alle so
als union haben wir aber 2017 das online
zugangs gesetz auf den weg gebracht
sämtliche dienstleistungen der
öffentlichen hand müssen bis ende diesen
jahres bis ende 2022 digital zur
verfügung gestellt werden mit dem
zukunftspaket haben wir zusätzliche
milliarden mitte 20 20 für die umsetzung
zur verfügung gestellt das heißt die
voraussetzungen sind geschaffen von der
register modernisierung bis zum
digitalen unternehmens konto jetzt muss
die bundesregierung einfach nur umsetzen
und drittens gerade in dieser zeit wird
deutlich dass wir partner in der welt
brauchen politisch aber auch
wirtschaftlich das freihandelsabkommen
mit kanada liegt auf dem tisch wir legen
es in jeder sitzungswoche wieder auf dem
tisch eine stimme für ct ist in der
stimme für wohlstand und eine stimme für
den zusammenhalt in der westlichen welt
mit und stimmen sie diesen abkommen
bildern
vielen dank herr kollege lutz
nächste gegnerin ist die kollegin lene
werden der spd-fraktion lena werner von
der spd ist mitglied im
wirtschaftsausschuss für die spd
bundestagsfraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe 9b des thomas
morus gymnasium aus meinem wahlkreis um
auf der tribüne liebe unionsfraktion
haben wir das gleiche verständnis von
dem wort sofort laut duden bedeutet es
innerhalb kürzester zeit und ohne
weitere verzögerung wenn ich mir jetzt
ihren antrag anschaue dann stellt sich
mir die frage wie all die maßnahmen die
sicher teilweise auch richtig sind
unverzüglich umgesetzt werden sollen ihr
antrag liegt auch keine sofortmaßnahmen
fest hier finden wir fast das gesamte
wahlprogramm der union und teilweise
sogar vorhaben die sie versuchen seit
jahren
mit vielen jahre feststellung stimme ich
überein die korona pandemie bedeutet
weiterhin eine belastung für viele
unternehmen dazu kommen nun die
auswirkungen des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die energieversorgung
und die lieferketten wir müssen alles
daran setzen die belastung für die
menschen und auch die unternehmen in der
aktuellen lage so gering wie möglich zu
halten und wir stehen vor einem
jahrzehnt der wirtschaftlichen
transformation wobei ich in diesem punkt
nicht ganz überein stimmen denn die
transformation hat bereits begonnen
wir von der spd bundestagsfraktion sowie
die bundesregierung arbeiten bereits mit
hochdruck an all diesen punkten um die
unternehmen und beschäftigten sofort zu
entlasten
in ihrem antrag lassen sie komplett
außen vor das bereits maßnahmen auf den
weg gebracht wurden da sie uns hier eine
sehr lange liste vorgelegt haben möchte
ich jetzt nur auf wenige punkte eingehen
und diese klar stellen sie fordern unter
anderem temporäre unterstützung für
besonders von der krise betroffenen
unternehmen genau darauf hat man sich
doch in der bundesregierung bereits
geeinigt für unternehmen die vom
russischen angriffskrieg und dessen
folgen betroffen sind steht bereits ein
umfassendes maßnahmenpaket zur verfügung
mit dem kfw kreditprogramm und dem
bürgschaftsprogramm werden schnell in
liquiditätsnöten für unternehmen
sichergestellt diese maßnahmen können
schon in dieser bzw in der nächsten
woche starten einen direkten zuschuss zu
den stromkosten können die unternehmen
beantragen die von deutlich gestiegenen
energiekosten betroffen sind im
härtesten frei erhalten betroffene
unternehmen bis zu 50 millionen euro an
zuschüssen zur strom- und gaskosten
alleine diese maßnahme wird
voraussichtlich einen umfang von bis zu
sechs milliarden euro haben zu behaupten
die wirtschaft finde in den
leistungspaketen kaum berücksichtigung
ist deswegen schlichtweg falsch
im zuge des antrags fordern sie außerdem
ein sofortprogramm für beschäftigte mit
den leistungspaketen der ampelkoalition
von februar/märz sorgen wir bereits für
massive entlastungen für die bürgerinnen
und bürger und das nicht nur bei den
energiekosten nur heute nur noch heute
werden wir über den wegfall der
eeg-umlage entscheiden und somit werden
ab dem ersten juli alle verbraucher
indirekt und bezüglich entlastet
darüber hinaus wurden massive
steuerentlastung beschlossen hinzu kommt
eine erhöhung des
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrags sowie der
pendlerpauschale und einmalzahlungen für
beschäftigte über 300 euro um für
direkte und schnelle entlastungen zu
sorgen dass ein euro ticket für den öpnv
steht für jede bürgerin und jeden bürger
ab dem ersten juni zur verfügung und ja
ich gehe auch davon aus dass dies im
ländlichen raum aktiv genutzt wird aus
meinem wahlkreis bitburg habe ich schon
von vielen gehört die das angebot sehr
sehr gerne nutzen wollen zu guter letzt
schließlich auch eine absenkung der
energie steuern auf kraftstoffe an die
maßnahmen an dies sind konkrete
entlastungen von denen die verbraucher
innen direkt und unmittelbar profitieren
wir müssen zukunftsfähige soziale und
vor allem nachhaltige wirtschaftspolitik
machen als junger mensch einer
generation die bisher in jeglicher weise
hinsichtlich sicherheit gelebt hat bin
ich mir der verantwortung die wir für
unser land haben mehr als bewusst
besonders durch den russischen
angriffskrieg in der ukraine stehen wir
jetzt vor der großen herausforderung
unser land unsere gesellschaft und
unsere wirtschaft in eine neue zeit zu
führen dass wir nicht so weitermachen
können wie bisher wird nicht mehr allein
durch die klimakrise getrieben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen was wir
brauchen ist weitsicht eine
differenzierte analyse der
herausforderung und passgenaue lösung
ich danke daher der bundesregierung für
die bereits auf den weg gebrachten
maßnahmen für die bevölkerung und
unternehmen die sofort helfen
insbesondere in der aktuellen situation
ist eine konstruktive und
zielorientierte oppositionsarbeit
besonders wichtig anträge wie diese
helfen dabei nicht weiter es geht um
unsere zukunft vielen dank
vielen dank frau wo die sonne
also ja zügig achten plötzlich sehe ist
jedoch als nächste hat das wurde der
parlamentarische
staatssekretär michael kellner für die
bundesregierung hätte sie schon vermisst
weil auf der regierungsbank kennt diesen
erwartet
danke
dass sie hinter ihrer maske nicht nicht
deutlich erkennbar da gab präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren wir sind eine
koalition die handelt und handel den
zeichen wo die wirtschaft belastet ist
immer noch von den nachwirkungen von der
korona pandemie und jetzt von dem
brutalen krieg russlands in der ukraine
lasst mich sagen was handeln heißt wir
schaffen zum ersten juli die eeg umlage
ab davon profitiert der handwerker auf
dem land genauso wie der händler in der
innenstadt
mit den oster paket machen wir es für
unternehmen attraktiver selber in ihrem
betriebsstätten in grünen strom zu
investieren wir nehmen dort die abgaben
runter wir nehmen dort die bürokratie
runter der steve gerade dem mittelstand
dem rückgrat unserer wirtschaft also der
nächste punkt um den behandeln
voraussichtlich nächste woche starten
wir mit dem kfw programm und ein
bürgschaftsprogramm um liquidität der
unternehmen liquidität zu sichern die
durch die ukraine krise unverschuldet in
schwierigkeiten gekommen sind und wir
machen ein neues zuschussprogramm zur
temporären kostendämpfung des
preisanstieges bei erdgas und strom für
energieintensive unternehmen wie im
internationalen wettbewerb stehen ca
4000 unternehmen 5 milliarden euro damit
erhalten wir die internationale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit
damit dämpfen wir den schock wir können
aber dass wir es auch klar sagen wir
können nicht alle preissteigerungen
ausgleichen
wir helfen deswegen zielgerichtet dass
dieser krieg keine belastung keine
kosten für die deutsche gesellschaft für
die unternehmen für die wirtschaft mit
sich bringt das können wir nicht
versprechen dass ist nicht möglich und
das sollten wir auch so ehrlich sagen
wer meint es gäbe eine belastung das ist
doch der coup dornieden welt was da
geschieht diese ehrlichkeit die würde
ich mir wünschen diversifizieren die
energieversorgung dass er nie wieder so
abhängig sind wie wir es von russland
waren und teilweise sind ich will mich
wir machen uns auf den weg die
unternehmen machen sie einen weg stellen
ihre lieferketten um sie helfen
geflüchteten sie unterstützten die
sanktionen dafür danke ich ihnen recht
herzlich wir legen gemeinsam einen pfad
raus aus der totalen abhängigkeit müssen
schneller werden mit der
dekarbonisierung mit der sozial
ökologischen transformation
das liegt im interesse des klimaschutzes
mit der nationalen sicherheit und des
wirtschaftlichen wohlstands herzlichen
dank
michael kellner der parlamentarische
staatssekretär beim bundesministerium
für wirtschaft und klimaschutz er hat
noch mal gesagt wir als bundesregierung
helfen zielgerichtet dass dieser krieg
eine ökonomische belastungen mit sich
bringt das können wir nicht versprechen
wir können die belastung nur atmen
lernen gitta connemann jetzt für die
cdu/csu
herr präsident meine damen und herren
eine wohnung urlaub
soziale sicherheit gute ausbildung für
kinder das wünschen sich alle am ende
wohlstand für alle
dieses ziel hat ludwig erhard
ist deutschland groß geworden sein
erfolgsmodell die soziale
marktwirtschaft freiheit und
verantwortung getragen von betrieben und
mitarbeitern
99 prozent davon sind mittelständler
handwerk handel gewerbe industrie das
rückgrat unserer gesellschaft motor für
innovation garant für arbeitsplätze und
ausbildung die übrigens nicht in
jahresabschlüssen denken sondern in
generationen die risiko und
verantwortung übernehmen die deshalb aus
unserer sicht der union ein recht auf
unser vertrauen auf unseren respekt
haben
das erleben sie häufig nicht das
unternehmerbild wird verzerrt wir haben
es hier aktuell erlebt wie in einer zeit
in der der mittelstand so viel schultert
übrigens sich auch bei den flüchtlingen
engagiert von krisen oder
kriegsgewinnler spricht das ist einfach
nur erbärmlich
abgabenlast arbeitskräftemangel
regulierungswahn das gehört zum alltag
zur wahrheit gehört wir als gruppe haben
dazu auch beigetragen hier eine gesetz
dort eine verordnung der mittelstand
konnte es aber schultern bislang aber
jetzt ist die schmerzgrenze erreicht
pandemie krieg lockdown in shanghai
lieferketten die brechen rohstoffe
vielen preise explodieren inflation es
gibt keine planungssicherheit der
mittelstand kommt aus dem krisenmodus
nicht mehr heraus deshalb stehen wir am
rande einer rezession
deutschland hat viele krisen erlebt
wir können auch diese meistern aber nur
mit unseren unternehmerinnen und
unternehmern mit den mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern diese wissen wie es
geht und dafür brauchen sie keinen
amtsvormund liebe ampel sondern sie
brauchen einen befreiungsschlag
dafür legen wir ihnen ein
entfesselungskünstler
mit der mittelstand seine kraft wieder
frei entfalten kann denn der wohlstand
fällt nicht vom himmel
dazu gehört den menschen etwas
zuzutrauen dafür brauchen wir einen
belastungsstopp ein bürokratie
moratorium national aber auch europäisch
auf der agenda der eu stehen zurzeit
dutzende von neuen reglementierungen
brüssel dts zum beispiel mit der
taxonomie vorgaben machen wer wann wo
investiert damit griff diskreditiert
auch die kommission übrigens die europa
idee und dabei brauchen wir gerade jetzt
europa mehr denn je wir brauchen den
einsatz für offene märkte für internet
signale freihandelsabkommen wie z
die aussetzung hier scheitert an der
ampel und das ist unverantwortlich für
die exportnation deutschland
aber hier wird er kinder auf
umverteilung statt wachstum gesetzt auch
hier in der debatte bestes schlechtestes
beispiel ihre steuerpolitik stadt zu
entlasten wird kassiert bei sprit bei
strom ja die ampel hat entlastung
angekündigt aber die mit r helfen kommt
zu spät und gehen mit paketen wie in
ihrem energie preisgeld an rentnern
studenten mini-jobbern und übrigens dem
mittelstand vorbei den traum vom
eigenheim haben sie sowieso schon
geschrottet mit der mit der abschaffung
der förderung gehälter müssen mit der
inflation schritt halten können derzeit
wird aber der lohnausgleich vom start
weg gesteuert die ampel sie zu kassiert
und verteilt dann um aber der staat ist
kein buschehr die bürger und betriebe
brauchen keine almosen sondern sie
brauchen entlastung technologieoffenheit
statt ideologie eigenverantwortung statt
auflagen auch für digitale
transformation und energiewende nur dann
wird unser land seine
wettbewerbsfähigkeit bewahren und dafür
legen wir ihnen ein programm vor im
sinne dessen was ludwig er haben wollte
und möglich machte wohlstand für alle
herzlichen dank
gitta connemann endet mit ludwig erhard
das ist auch klar denn sie ist die
vorsitzende
mittelstandsvereinigung der union und
die cdu legt hier einen antrag vor
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigte und fordert darin unter
anderem ein belastungsmoratorium
steuerliche entlastung zum beispiel
ausgeweitete
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten steuerliche
verluste über die krisenjahre 20 bis 22
hinaus jens bike für die spd ich
verstehe sie ein stück weit wir alle
ja das ist hilft ihnen auch nicht viel
weiter ich weiß aber wir alle haben das
zdf politbarometer von anfang april
gesehen und wir alle haben gesehen dass
nur 18 prozent der menschen in diesem
land war die union die größte
wirtschaftskompetenz vermuten
die mensch habe das zutrauen in ihrer
wirtschaftspolitik verloren und
mittlerweile sehen sie vollkommen zu
recht da die größten kompetenzwerte auch
bei der spd und dann ist man bei der
opposition natürlich gefragt man muss
was tun und dann fängt man anträge zu
schreiben aber ich sage ihnen auch
dieser antrag wird ihnen da nicht helfen
sie fordern ernsthaft und weiterbetrieb
von atomkraftwerken zu prüfen da waren
sie schon mal weiter und auch das diw
ist deutsche institut für
wirtschaftsforschung hat nochmal 2009 10
bekräftigt atomkraft war nie eine
saubere keine kostengünstige
energiequelle nicht sein
sie fordern dann eine neuauflage des
freihandels abkommen tipp ein
freihandelsabkommen mit dem unternehmen
auf vermeintlich entgangene gewinne
klagen sollen aber arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmerrechte gar keine rolle
spielten und da sind weite teile des
antrags man sagen kann liebe cdu csu die
neunziger jahre haben sich gemeldet sie
hätten gern ihre wirtschaftliche
programmatik zurück denn gute und
fortschrittliche wirtschafts und
arbeitsmarktpolitik muss zusammengedacht
werden
und obwohl ihr antrag die beschäftigten
im titel trägt finden die de facto wie
im antrag ja gar nicht statt wir aber
wissen der wirtschaftliche erfolg
anzunehmen hinten maßgeblich von seinen
beschäftigten ab und deswegen haben wir
auch und auch das findet keine erwähnung
die sonderregeln zum kurzarbeitergeld
verlängert aber der leichte zugang der
heute leistung satz längere bezugsdauer
erstattung von
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
keine erwähnung wert
und obwohl ist das kriseninstrument
schlechthin war acht millionen menschen
haben so einen arbeitsplatz gerettet
bekommen und wir haben herr bremen hat
das angesprochen auch die
liquiditätsengpässe von unternehmen
überwunden und ihnen geholfen diese zu
überwinden aber auch das findet keine
erwähnung
auch nicht dass es ein internationales
vorbild war frankreich großbritannien
die usa haben es kopiert es war 2009
schon der garant für das deutsche
jobwunder all das findet keinen
unternehmen erwähnung und das ist der
grund warum die menschen mittlerweile
mehr vertrauen in unsere
wirtschaftspolitik haben als in ihre war
für uns klar ist gute
arbeitsmarktpolitik ist gute
wirtschaftspolitik beides geht nur
zusammen
für uns zählt der erhalt von
arbeitsplätzen für uns ist eine gute
lohnentwicklung wichtig denn gerade wenn
es export probleme gibt wenn wir
konjunkturelle flaute name ist wichtig
die binnennachfrage zu stärken und
deswegen gilt für uns die wirtschaft
dient in erster linie menschen und nicht
umgekehrt
und das werden wir dann auch gleich
sehen bei der beratung zum gesetzentwurf
über die mindestlohn in höhe von 12 euro
die folgt wenn sie uns auch unterstützen
möchte binnennachfrage zu stärken gut
die wirtschaftspolitik zu machen dann
stimmen sie diesem antrag leicht zu und
dass ich möchte man sagen mit dem vor
dem wirtschafts helfen ja schon erwähnt
wurden dem kurzarbeitergeld mindestlohn
sichernde arbeitsplätze helfen den
unternehmen in deutschland stärkt die
binnennachfrage und bringen unser land
durch die krise herzlichen dank
jens pike der sozialdemokrat wies auf
den nächsten punkt hinten den der
bundestag beraten wird das flaggschiff
sozusagen der spd bemühungen 12 euro
mindestlohn aber das kommt erst nachher
im moment berät der bundestag hier ein
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigte antrag antrag der cdu csu
jetzt felix landschaft für die grünen
würden sie haben einen großen
amerikanischen polit strategen schritt
zitiert ich möchte ihnen ein zitat eines
großen sozialdemokraten entgegenhalten
politik beginnt mit der betrachtung der
wirklichkeit und was sie heute hier
dargestellt haben auch sie herr bremen
was sie alles nicht passieren würde nur
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger nicht viel unternehmen das hat
schlicht mit der realität nichts zu tun
der parlamentarische trägt er als
ausgeführt und viele andere auch und
wenn ich mit ihren antrag hier anschaue
dann habe ich mich ein bisschen versetzt
gefühlt in der autofahrt und im
hintergrund läuft hielt radio 990 sm das
beste aus den 80ern 90ern und die super
hits von heute das ist aber nicht das
was wir brauchen
wie super jetzt von heute genau wenn ich
mir ich bin nur ich will nur als im
klassischen paar dinge darstellen der
kollege roloff hat auch einiges
angesprochen belastungsmoratorium
sämtliches außerkraftsetzung
lieferketten regulierung all das würde
jetzt gerade nicht gehen der
rohrkrepierer chip als die verheißung
einer großartigen zukunft und dann und
das muss man mir wirklich mal erklären
in der aktuellen situation helfen soll
das was sie schon immer gefordert haben
nämlich die arbeitszeit regulierung
dahingehend und verbrechen dass man in
betrieben statt die begrenzte
arbeitszeit am tag das einfach auf die
woche aufzuteilen wie das ein beitrag
dazu sein soll lieferketten
problematiken produktionsengpässe
produktions rückführung energiepreis
problematik hin zu bekämpfen das hat
doch nichts mit der realität nichts zu
tun und deswegen habe ich mich gefreut
über einen satz aus ihrem anschlag
entscheidend dass einerseits die
aktuellen krisen zu überwinden und
andererseits die wirtschaftspolitischen
weichen entschlossen auf
leistungsfähigkeit digitalisierung und
nachhaltigkeit zu stellen ein guter satz
daraus folgt bei ihnen überhaupt nichts
nada niente wenn sie das ernst meint
überdenken sie bitte ob das eine kluge
idee war gegen den nachtragshaushalt zu
klagen der 60 milliarden euro genau für
diese transformationen die sie
ansprechen zur verfügung stellen soll
das während beitrag dazu dieses land in
die zukunft zu führen vielen dank
vielen dank damit schließt sich die
aussprache und wir nähern uns der
entscheidung zunächst tagesordnungspunkt
13 wir kommen zur abstimmung über den
antrag der fraktion der cdu/csu auch
drucksache 1999 mit dem titel
sofortprogramm für unternehmen und
beschäftigte der stimmen für diesen
antrag
wer stimmt dagegen
wer enthält sich dann ist dieser antrag
bei enthaltung der fraktionen
gegen die stimmen der cdu csu fraktion
den stimmen der fraktionen des hauses
abgelehnt ich rufe auf zusatzpunkt vier
abstimmung welche antrag der fraktion
die linke drucksache 1514 mit dem titel
hilfsprogramm für wirtschaft wohlstand
beschäftigung wäre stimmt für diesen
antrag das ist die fraktion die linke
stimmte dagegen
der rest des hauses damit ist dieser
antrag abgelehnt ich rufe auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 7a und 7b erste
beratungen ist von der bundesregierung
eingebrachten gesetzentwurfs zur
erhöhung des schutzes durch den
gesetzlichen mindestlohn und zu
änderungen im bereich die geringfügigen
beschäftigung sowie beratung des antrags
der fraktion die linke mit dem titel
ausweitung der minijobs konterkariert
erhöhung des gesetzlichen mindestlohns
für die aussprache wurde eine dauer von
68 minuten beschlossen
bitte die kolleginnen kollegen den
sitzplatz wechsel doch möglichst zügig
vorzunehmen das geht auch für die
fraktionen von fdp und bündnis 90 die
grünen
ja zwölf euro mindestlohn bald soll aus
dem zentralen wahlkampfversprechen des
kanzlers realität werden auch die grenze
für mini-jobs wird angehoben hierfür hat
die bundesregierung den entwurf eines
mindestlohn erhöhung des gesetzes
vorgelegt der nun in erster lesung
beraten wird und auch die linke hat den
antrag eingebracht und als erster redet
der bundesarbeits und sozialminister
hubertus heil
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen und kommenden sonntag ist
der tag der arbeit der erste mai ein
feiertag mit wirklich stolze tradition
ein tag auf den ich mich als
arbeitsminister freude aber auch ganz
persönlich ein tag mit großer tradition
aber es geht eben auch um hochaktuelle
themen sonntag werden viele millionen
menschen auf der welt auf die straße
gehen die werte wie frieden für freiheit
für soziale gerechtigkeit und
solidarität
am ersten mal geht es natürlich aber
auch immer wieder um den wert und die
würde der arbeit es geht darum meine
damen und herren das millionen von
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer das
bekommen was ihnen zusteht anständige
arbeitsbedingungen und eben auch faire
löhne und dazu gehört auch die erhöhung
des mindestlohns
also wenn meine damen und herren wir
sind heute hier um eine zusage
einzulösen ein versprechen mehr respekt
auch dafür ist diese bundesregierung
angetreten wer respekt für diejenigen
die tag für tag dafür sorgen dass der
laden läuft die großes leisten und das
oftmals für kleines geld die rede ist
ganz konkret von verkäuferin in einer
bäckerei arbeiten von denjenigen die als
helferin der landwirtschaft tätig sind
oder auch von friseurinnen und meine
damen und herren es sind gerade diese
menschen
mit kleineren und normalen einkommen die
sich schon während der pandemie den
letzten zwei jahren große sorgen gemacht
haben und jetzt besonders beunruhigt
sind angesichts von steigenden preisen
die bundesregierung hat deswegen dafür
gesorgt dass besonders diese menschen in
der jetzigen krise entlastet werden
deswegen haben wir entlastungs paket auf
den weg gebracht um härten abzufedern
wir entlasten damit zum beispiel eine
familie mit normalem einkommen
arbeitnehmerin arbeitnehmer mit zwei
kinder beide eltern berufstätig
um mehr als 950 euro in diesem jahr
hinzu kommen individuelle entlastung
etwa beim strom bei kraftstoffen beim
nahverkehr dass meine damen und herren
ist politik für soziale stabilität in
unserem land
es kann nicht sein
dass gerade die menschen mit kleinen
einkommen die größten lasten tragen sie
haben und sie brauchen solidarität
präsident meine damen und herren mehr
respekt bedeutet auch dass wir gerade
jetzt den gesetzentwurf zur erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf den weg bringen die
evaluation also die untersuchung des
bestehenden mindestlohns aus dem jahre
2020 hat uns zwei klare botschaften auf
den weg gegeben
erstens die einführung des mindestlohns
ist ein erfolgsmodell es hat
sozialversicherungspflichtige arbeit
gesichert und höhere löhne für rund vier
millionen menschen schaffen ich kann
mich übrigens an die ideologischen
debatten aus der damaligen zeit
um die einführung des mindestlohns noch
sehr lebhaft erinnern damals waren
manche auf den plan die den untergang
der sozialen marktwirtschaft an die wand
gemalt haben präsenter weise sind dass
auch diejenigen die sich jetzt wieder zu
wort melden insofern sollten sie ihre
eigenen worte erinnern die wahrheit ist
das gegenteil ist richtig die einführung
des mindestlohns war und ist ein
sozialpolitischer meilenstein und ich
will mich auch heute noch dafür bedanken
dass meine amtsvorgängerin andrea nahles
das damals durchgesetzt
unser ziel muss es doch in einer
sozialen marktwirtschaft sein dass die
die vollzeit arbeiten auch davon leben
können und die zweite botschaft dieser
evaluation aus dem jahre 2020 war wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass sich der
mindestlohn angemessen weiterentwickelt
das ist sozialpolitisch geboten ist es
sozialstaatlich geboten auch angesichts
wie gesagt der aktuellen
preisentwicklung damit millionen von
menschen den anschluss an die arbeiten
damit in diesem land nicht verlieren
viele arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer ist
es deshalb wichtig dass die erhöhung des
mindestlohns jetzt kommt und auch
schnell kommt sogleich allerdings
fordern arbeitgeber und ihre verbände
dass es einen hinreichenden vorlauf
dafür gibt ich und die bundesregierung
sind überzeugt dass mit dem
inkrafttreten zum ersten oktober 2022
wie ein fairer und auch schonender
interessenausgleich gelungen ist denn
klar ist dass die weiterentwicklung des
mindestlohns als instrument des
sozialstaates eine aufgabe des
gesetzgebers ist
gleichzeitig will ich betonen dass das
bewährte system der
sozialpartnerschaftlich verhandelten
mindestlöhne damit nicht grundsätzlich
in frage gestellt wird wir wollen es nur
insofern anpassen oder das erforderlich
ist um für angemessenen mindestschutz
für arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer zu
sorgen da es auch
dass die mindestlohn kommission in
zukunft weitere anpassungen übernehmen
wird und das heißt dass damit auch die
sozialpartner rinnen und sozialpartner
eingebunden sind und natürlich meine
damen und herren ist der mindestlohn
auch nach dieser erhöhung immer nur eine
absolute lohnuntergrenze
die ist notwendig und zwölf euro das ist
ungefähr 60 prozent des mittleren
einkommens in deutschland so eine
vernünftige lohnuntergrenzen aber ich
sage auch uns als bundesregierung reicht
das nicht aus wir wollen wieder mehr
tarifbindung in deutschland und das
werden wir auch anreiz zu schützen
das hat nicht so dass ein
koalitionsvertrag verankert und
vereinbart haben dass beispielsweise
öffentliche aufträge des bundes
zukünftig nur an die unternehmen geben
sollen die nach tarif bezahlen meine
damen und herren das ist dort reger
anreiz gesetzt
mit diesem gesetzentwurf sorgen wir
dafür dass der mindestlohn zum ersten
oktober 2022 also auf 12 euro steigt wer
vollzeit dann zumindest und arbeitet
verdient bisher brutto rund 1700 euro
dann rund 2100 euro und ich will noch
mal sagen wer davon vor allen dingen
profitiert millionen von menschen vor
allem frauen die haben arbeitsmarkt
arbeiten den laden am laufen halten und
auch sehr viele beschäftigte in
ostdeutschland das ist eine lohnerhöhung
von rund 22 prozent das haben wir
versprochen und wir machen dass meine
darunter
und ich sage das gerade in diesen zeiten
wir haben am heutigen vormittag zu recht
über frieden und über äußere sicherheit
gesprochen aber das ist kein gegensatz
zu sozialer stabilität im inneren im
gegenteil meine damen und herren äußere
sicherheit und innerer sozialer frieden
sind zwei seiten einer medaille
deshalb geht es nicht im krisen
management oder sozialen fortschritt wir
müssen beides schaffen in deutschland
unser sozialstaat meine damen und herren
und auch unsere soziale marktwirtschaft
sind stark der sozialstaat sorgt für
verlässlichen schutz und
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt gerade
auch in zeiten der krise und unser ziel
und dafür leistet die erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf 12 auch einen wichtigen
beitrag ist und bleibt ein starkes und
ein faires deutschland herzlichen werden
der zuständige bundesarbeitsminister hat
die einführung des mindestlohnes durch
seine vorgängerin andrea nahles als
meilenstein gelobt
sozialpartnerschaftlich verhandelte
mindestlöhne wolle man nicht ausbremsen
man wolle nur den für einen
mindestschutz sorgen die arbeitgeber
sind der meinung sie lehnen staatliche
lohnfestsetzung ab und wollen eventuell
gegen dagegen klagen stephan stracke
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
der union
unter führung der union in der
kanzlerschaft von angela merkel haben
wir den allgemeinen gesetzlichen
mindestlohn in deutschland zum ersten
januar 2015 eingeführt wir haben dies in
diesem bewusstsein getan dass gute
arbeit in deutschland auch fair entlohnt
werden muss dort wo der
tarifvertraglichen schutz nicht oder
nicht hinreichend ausgebildet ist
braucht es eine angemessene
lohnuntergrenze um zu verhindern dass
der wettbewerb zwischen unternehmen auf
den rücken von beschäftigten ausgetragen
wird und wir wollen auch damit dafür
sorgen dass man von dem lohn auch
tatsächlich leben kann der mindestlohn
hat sich bewährt durch die beschlüsse
der mindestlohn kommission liegt die
höhe des mindestlohns aktuell bei
982 sie steigt zum ersten juli dieses
jahres noch einmal weiter auf 10 eur 45
und nun soll der mindestlohn auf 12 euro
erhöht werden dieser erfolg jetzt nicht
auf der grundlage der beschlüsse der
mindestlohn kommission sondern durch
eine politische setzung des gesetzgebers
und ich will an dieser stelle hier ganz
klar sagen ein mindestlohn von 12 euro
ist angemessen und erst richtig 12 euro
sind
eine wichtige
unterstützung von menschen mit geringen
einkommen
6 millionen arbeitnehmern arbeitnehmer
profitieren davon der minister hat
darauf hingewiesen es sind überwiegend
frauen und sie sind es ja die infolge
von mehrfachbelastungen familie und
beruf in einklang zu bringen häufiger im
niedriglohnbereich beschäftigt sind und
deshalb auch niedriger renten haben
und zugleich bleibt aber auch der
hinweis richtig dass wir in einer
sozialen marktwirtschaft wieder unsrigen
keine politische lohnfindung wollen das
lehnen wir ab ein überbietungswettbewerb
in der höhe von löhnen meistens
vorgetragen ja dann zu wahlkampfzeiten
ist
brandgefährlich ein solcher wettbewerb
schwächt die sozialpartnerschaft wir
brauchen jedoch starke arbeitgeber
starke gewerkschaften und wir dürfen sie
nicht beschädigen und letztendlich würde
ein solcher überbietungswettbewerb wenn
er auf dauer ausgetragen würde zu lasten
der schwächsten am arbeitsmarkt gehen
denn sie sind es die
letztendlich durch neue
eintrittsbarrieren in den arbeitsmarkt
gehindert werden wir brauchen jedoch
nicht neue hürden sondern weniger und
wir wollen auch dass der erhöhte
mindestlohn von 12 euro tatsächlich bei
den menschen ankommt und zwar dauerhaft
eine vollzeitbeschäftigte arbeitskraft
mit 40 stunden beispielsweise für sie
bedeutet die erhöhung ein einkommensplus
von brutto 270 euro er verdient rund 15
prozent mehr gegenüber einem mindestlohn
in höhe von zehn euro 45 er muss aber 48
prozent mehr steuern zahlen im
verhältnis also muss er mehr steuern
zahlen als vorher und ursache dafür ist
die gestaltung des steuertarifs wir
nennen das auch kalte progression und
die kalte progression ist es die wir
verhindern müssen in diesem bereich
damit diese erhöhung des mindestlohns
tatsächlich auch bei den menschen
ankommt von 12 euro die kalt und klammen
hände des bundesfinanzministers dürfen
nicht tief in die taschen der
geringverdiener sich hinein graben und
hier ist die bundesregierung gefordert
tatsächlich aktiv zu werden den effekt
den effekt der kalten progression auch
abzuschaffen und das bleiben sie
tatsächlich schuldig wir brauchen mehr
netto vom brutto und hier liefert die
bundesregierung an dieser stelle nicht
und das ist etwas passiert mengen und
auch klammer und ein zweiter effekt der
hinzu kommt
der ist der steigenden sozialbeiträgen
die entwicklung der abgabenlast kennt
absehbar bei dieser koalition nur eine
entwicklung und zwar die nach oben eine
krankenversicherung ist für rund 17
milliarden euro für 20 23 bei der
pflegeversicherung auch da ein defizit
bei der rente und bei der
arbeitslosenversicherung sind ja bereits
erhöhungen entsprechend angekündigt es
droht in diesem jahr auf der ganzen
breite 1 beitragssatz zunahme und auch
hier ist die bundesregierung gefordert
die bei die sozialbeiträge stabil zu
halten denn sie sind ist letztendlich
die es in besonderem maße
geringverdiener belasten wir haben das
gemacht als union mit unserer sozial
garantie von 40 prozent diese koalition
bleibt diesen ansatz schuldig
und ein dritter effekt kommt hinzu
es ist der massive kaufkraftverluste den
wir derzeit erfahren von 7 prozent in
diesem in diesem monat das merken wir
bei den grundnahrungsmitteln bei den
spritpreisen bei den heizkosten auch das
belastet natürlich
bezieherinnen und bezieher gerade von
geringen einkommen in massiver art und
weise und auch da muss diese koalition
mehr tun als sie es tatsächlich nach
doch auch hier ist wieder der ansatz der
steuer hier können sie zeigen dass sie
tatsächlich dafür sorge tragen dass die
erhöhung von zwei auf zwölf euro
mindestlohn tatsächlich auch bei den
menschen ankommt und die mindest
lohnerhöhung davon sollen ja auch
diejenigen profitieren die in einem
minijob beschäftigt sind das ist richtig
dass dies getan wird nötig ist als auch
und richtig dass diese dynamisiert wird
und sie gehen auch eine teilzeit falle
an nämlich den übergang zwischen minijob
und midijob aber das was sie tun ist
nicht die lösung auch da müssen sie an
das steuerrecht hin amtieren um die
teilzeit falle tatsächlich wirksam zur
detail zu beseitigen es bleibt viel zu
tun für diese koalition um es richtig zu
machen
stirn stracke für die cdu/csu hat gesagt
ein mindestlohn von 12 euro ist
angemessen und richtig wir wollen
allerdings keine politischen finden und
es bleibe das problem dass durch diesen
mindestlohn nicht genug geld im
portemonnaie der arbeitnehmer bleibt
durch die kalte progression der
steuertarif er müsse verändert wird
frank zilles gespräche für arbeit und
soziales der bündnisgrünen 2015 eine
gesetzliche lohnuntergrenze eingezogen
wurde
befanden sich die löhne in vielen
bereichen auf einer rutschbahn nach
unten begünstigt durch eine sinkende
tarifbindung
mitgliedschaften arbeitgeberverbänden
ohne tarifbindung und das ausscheren
viele unternehmen aus tarifverträgen
führten dazu dass immer mehr menschen
statt von tarifverträgen geschützt zu
sein sich konfrontiert sagen mit der
rückkehr von unsicherheit damit das
eigene leben im zeichen prekäre